One, two, three, one, three, two, one, three, two, one,
three.
Wait, I already switched.
I did too.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Hi.
Hi, everybody.
Hi, hi, hi, hi booze and hi wisps.
My new community name.
Hello wisps.
I can't say your community name.
Oh, hello.
I believe in you.
I'm going to force Minto to say whips again.
Don't do this to me.
I'm getting bullied.
I'm getting bullied bugged.
I would never do that.
Wait, hold on.
Sorry.
I increased the gain on your mic.
So I might OBS.
So you might have like audibly flash banged people.
Suddenly I'm like, you were doing this before.
also fuck you nani don't redeem end stream i'm not gonna
even refund you you knew what you were going into what a
bastard yeah what a bastard that guy you don't even get a
refund steal his money steal his money wait it's yeah i want
to steal your berry coin your berry coin yeah yeah berry's
bugging me you guys help yeah it's true i just appeared in
her room and i was like let's play block i think no i think
i was the one hounding you a little bit i was like barry do
you want to play battle block we need to finish 50 games i
got i got i got threatened by some i booze for if we don't
finish this game today that they'll kill me in real life i'm
kind of mad about that i feel like they have no faith in us
that we are gamers yeah no we got this we got this we got
this this is so freaking this is easy easy peasy Yeah.
Well, even though it's been two months since we last played
and we don't remember how to play.
Cut to two hours later when I'm on the floor dying.
I'm like, walk in!
Walk in, baby!
We got this!
It's over, it's over, guys.
This might be my final stream.
What?
Oh, well, they did say end stream.
Is that like indefinitely or?
Yeah, imagine.
I quit streaming.
i quit battle block theater made me quit streaming how easy
is peasy like applesauce like pretty pretty peasy yeah yeah
what who i boo's threatened you you
want names i'll write down a list of names you guys are
screwed after the stream i need names
um i'm gonna write every i boo that's in um your fan discord
so you just get mad at all of them oh okay good my
controller disconnected so we're good okay we're good the
guy above me yeah the everyone below the guy above everyone
below uh all the mods all the steiner steiner did it steiner
catching strays again this guy
Hattington, that guy, Hattington, uh, uh, Steiner again.
My manager is getting the axe.
He's, it's over, man.
You're going to get haunted now for real.
Haunted negative.
Negative.
There's no negative.
We're haunting everybody.
In parentheses, negative.
No, never think that.
Haunting is always positive.
Like a bug infestation is always positive.
Exactly, exactly.
Who wouldn't want thousands of little berry bugs?
Like, oh my god, wait.
I don't know.
That sounds disgusting.
To you.
I know, to me, even to me, that sounds disgusting.
I can imagine them all at the feet of someone being like,
just all randomly spewing, like, Fujo nonsense.
Yeah, or, like, I'm, like, accidentally rage-baiting.
I still can't.
it over and the off collab like ashen being like she was she
said something she was like girl you are testing me this
trip yeah yeah i think about it all the time too where she's
like uh i think her exact words were very pleased this
weekend you have been testing me my favorite accidental rage
baiter yeah oh my god she she sounded so tired i was like
damn was i really doing all that You're doing too much.
I was doing too much, I guess.
My bad.
Yeah, you've been bugging her.
Yeah, I've been bugging her.
That's the thing.
It's just so funny how you say things and you're so wrong.
You're so confident.
You're so wrong.
It's because I just, I just, I vocalize my thoughts.
So even if I think they're wrong, I say it out loud to hear
how it sounds and then to like really make sure.
But because there are people around me, it's like, oh, maybe
I should have said it out loud.
I think that's a good way of learning if you're wrong,
though.
How would you know your brain might be like, like if you
think it inside and you're like, this sounds correct, you
know, you might never know if you're wrong.
Oh, I don't know if you talked about it, but I keep
remembering like, um, at Disney the avatar ride where the
one we got turned on on no we don't don't drag me don't drag
me into your freaky world I did not get turned on who was it
that said that people get turned on on the ride it was
Ashton Ashton said it like a second before the ride started
just as like a quick by the way so there's this ride
everybody it's this avatar ride that like you sit on the
drag and you ride around on it.
The Banshee.
And like you can feel it breathing and stuff.
And Ashton was like, sometimes people get turned on on this
ride.
And afterwards, I'm a very honest ghost.
I said, yeah, I got turned on.
I mean.
Oh yeah, you said it.
We're all like, huh?
Nobody agreed with me.
Because we were like, we were just shocking.
It was just shocking.
Okay, but I'm like a monster fucker.
I felt like I was on a dragon.
So what do you want from me?
You can feel it breathing like in between your legs, you
guys.
You can.
It's very like, it's, I imagine that's what it feels like to
like ride a horse in real life.
Wait, don't say that.
Wait, no, that sounds bad.
What do you mean?
That sounds bad to me.
Like, wait.
Like, come on, man.
I read my Keenan was right there.
I don't mean it like that.
I don't mean it.
But people are going to be like, oh, Mint is going to get
turned on riding a horse.
people to think that okay okay anyways anyways that was a
fun ride though guys i recommend it was fun we like i think
we like actually did so much during like the short time we
were there you know barry maybe you should redeem that end
stream to give me no no i know we did so much yeah yeah yeah
i met it completely innocently yeah we almost died from the
gondola oh wait the god we got we got we got stuck in the
gondola for like a minute or two oh yeah we were i think
yeah yeah we were trapped that we were traveling between
parks and got stuck on a gondola yeah yeah it was fun though
it was very it was very rickety but i think that's probably
just all gondola or skyliners i should say yeah i have you
have you seen or rather have you ridden the the ferris wheel
at disneyland oh i haven't is that like the same have you
seen videos of it oh wait is it scary i i don't really have
a lot of experience with disneyland wait i'm gonna mute for
a second so i can tell my chat and also thank this super
chat okay okay wait wait i do hate yeah Oh, she, okay.
All right, guys.
Cheb, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I just wanted to say thank you for making my 2025 better
with your channel.
I was hoping it's not too much.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Is yesterday turned?
Or swarm, Cheb.
Happy birthday.
Thank you so much.
Sorry.
Anyways, I want to explain the Ferris wheel I'm talking
about at Disneyland.
It's like a Ferris wheel, but it shakes like crazy.
are videos of people like freaking out on it because it's
always it's like it's it's a ferris wheel like you think
it's fine and then like the booths in it like are rocking
back and forth like craziness i want to take berry on it
also thank you guys for the other super chat sorry i won't
be able to acknowledge them so much while we're gaming but
goto thank you beasties yeah clear yeah yeah and you thank
you guys i think there was one more i'm so sorry i missed it
though thank you thank you thank you okay back to our collab
hey come back what are you doing get the rock i heard
someone someone told me that you were celebrating a birthday
so i was trying to be i was trying to be like a cheerleader
did you guys know speaking of being a cheerleader did you
guys know that mint phantom is going to be singing jazz to
you soon next year next in two months like in February and
one month in one month practically oh my gosh don't say that
that's scary to me oh yeah sorry thanks for thanks for the
advertisement yeah you guys should pre-register you should
you guys should pre-sale you guys should camp out the jazz
club you guys should camp out the jazz club camp right now
starting now yeah starting now you gotta be ready yeah and
i'm singing jazz you guys like real jazz jazz yeah real jazz
and it up yeah no no no this isn't your mama's jazz club
this is real jazz or maybe maybe it's your grandmother's
jazz it's your grandma's jazz club yeah yeah think we're
going back to prohibition era everybody oh yeah min's gonna
be downing shots in the back like like a real mafioso i
think that's anti-prohibition right well no they were
definitely they were definitely drinking in prohibition
they're like oh yeah but yeah it'll be a secret place where
you can drink, but it's legal.
There'll be brewing concoctions that you've never seen
before in the back.
In the back.
Yeah.
You got to come up with the, you got to come up and say the
secret password.
I'm not going to say what it is, but you'll know.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Get jazzed about it.
Oh my God.
The bar is in the middle.
Wait, Barry, I think, wait, the bar is in the middle.
What do you mean bar is in the middle?
The bar of the the club is in the middle of the club but no
but you'll be brewing your like you'll have a cauldron in
the back oh cauldron it'll be like moonshine yeah like
moonshine yeah yeah yeah
just sing snake eater for like uh like a hundred songs
straight like a hundred times that night That's all that is.
That would be, wait, you know how long singing 100 times
takes?
Yeah.
Have you done it before?
No, but I've seen, I've seen some, I've seen some crazy
girls do it.
Yeah, they're crazy.
I've only done 50 times.
Yeah.
We'll go for 100 one day, guys.
What if I do it the day before my jazz show?
Stop.
We were just talking about this.
We need to like if you over exert yourself before the jazz
show We need it like the iBus need to like band together and
take away your stream key so that you can properly rest No
My voice would be like I would be in the club like Oh,
that's the worst outcome
No, no, no, no, you can't do that.
You can't do that You gotta be rested and proper I will have
you um you can okay you can be the i'll be the usher i'll be
like the i'll be the guard no but i'll do what okay so you
know how i as a ghost possess people don't you can't you
like get into people's brains and kind of infect like how do
you what do you do um i i don't know what kind of bugs
you've been talking to but i i just fly on people's
shoulders and stay there i don't i don't crawl into people's
ears.
What?
You're not like a parasite or?
Okay guys, thank you for coming to the collab.
Thanks guys.
Thank you so much.
Bye everybody.
Stay safe.
Stay warm.
It's over.
Wait, but like.
What the heck?
I've taught you like crawl into into the ears and get into
the brain.
Like you get one.
Like plankton.
No, you get one story of a ladybug being found in like a
random lady in China's colon.
And now, and now this is what...
Wait, that really happened?
Yeah, there's like a picture of it that goes around.
Or that when the story broke, there was a picture of it that
was going around of like this ladybug, just this random
ladybug in the colonoscopy.
Did you know the ladybug?
I can't answer that.
I wonder if the ladybug survived I think it did it kind of
seemed alive in the picture not all bugs know each other
okay but anytime there's a life is amazing everybody asks if
I know the ghost okay so you're you're inflicting that that
kind of prejudice sentence to me I am because I I am hurt
and so I must pain onto others because I too have been hurt.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
My bad.
It's like trauma.
Yeah, this is generational.
This is what happens.
We will stop the cycle.
You gotta stop the cycle of violence.
That's what Mariko said.
What an inspiration that guy is.
Hurt people hurt people it's true it's true it's true it's
true that's my ninja way yeah i will say i i really do love
i mean it has been only a few days i feel since you changed
your uh fan name to ibu but i love ibu because it reminds me
of yugioh why wasn't yugioh because because they they always
call like i think yugi yugi calls like his caribou uh like
eyeball oh yeah yeah yeah yeah eyeball eyeball they're your
eyeballs yeah my eyeballs yeah welcoming eyeballs and wisps
yeah and yeah wisps yeah wisps yeah wait i saw though you
said you might change bug bro oh yeah yeah yeah i said it on
my super secret account oh sorry i i want sorry it's okay
it's okay it's not a it's not a big secret but um i'm here
doxing oh my god Yeah, because I was like, well, bug bros, I
want something that's like a little, I mean, bug bros is
cute and I like it, but I want something, you know, if
people are like, I'm no bro of yours.
It's like, well, okay, what am I going to do then?
I think, no, I don't think anybody would say that.
Right.
Okay.
Maybe, maybe.
I think if they want to, if they even consider themselves a
bug bro, they would be like, yeah, you're my bro.
Yeah.
Um, that's true.
but i i i uh somebody recommended i switch it to lug the
boob the bug bugs the bug bugs is terrible
you even struggled saying it just now yeah the bug the bug
bugs you can't even say it properly
i can't even say the bug bugs why what do you mean you know
you don't like a labug bugs you stop is kind of crazy i know
it really makes like it does not flow well at all so you're
like in the middle of the sentence and you're like hi
everybody i'm the i'm the bug bug it's barry and the bug
bugs i think it definitely like looks better typed than it
is say say
People are gonna be like, I don't know, Barry just kind of
like, Barry just copies whatever Mint does.
Are you obsessed with me or something?
Yeah, I'm obsessed, I'm obsessed with you.
You know the Mickey Mouse cartoon where Minnie and Mickey
are like flirting or whatever and Mickey's like, I just
obsessed with you, like in a really disgusting way?
No.
Oh, it's like a recent cartoon.
It's like one of their recent.
style right yeah yeah yeah yeah he's so disgusting in it he
really is like i kind of like it yeah no i'm here for i feel
like it's like a revival of of this mickey mouse wait this
is like the same and i almost said anime oh my god the same
cartoon with the goofy vore no huh yeah i think so there's
an episode where there's like goofy eats he like he like
goes after Mickey yeah I have people in my chat saying yeah
okay I don't know that episode I only know um I don't I only
know the romantic one that Mickey and Minnie ah you're such
a romantic
it's because they make they make Mickey like so disgusting
they really do I sometimes though I you know the there's
like the the Mickey adventure whatever whatever it's called
the railroad oh yeah yeah yeah the ride yeah the ride and
the song in it runaway railroad yeah yeah yeah they have the
song and it's like nothing could stop us now I don't know I
don't make it better I sing that just kind of like walking
around it's cute it is cute hmm yeah I will say The top
moment, though, this year was definitely the fact that we,
when we were lining up for Guardians of the Galaxy Cosmic
Rewind, the ride, like all throughout the line, like the
one-hour wait, we were like, oh, I hope we get September.
I hope we get September.
And then when we wrote it, we actually got September.
I can't even express like when it shot us backwards and it
was just like, it and I was like I literally don't remember
what even happened on the ride.
I was just jamming out to September so hard.
Me too.
Like they were talking during the ride and I'm just like
party.
Yeah.
Like I was literally hands up in the air like jamming.
It was so fun.
We were like all dancing.
Yeah it was so fun.
It was so good.
It was really funny though after the ride ashton being like
wasn't that the best ride ever and then later she was like
wasn't that the best ride ever and everyone was like yeah it
was pretty good and she was like upset that nobody like she
told me later she was like why didn't everyone agree with me
this but cosmic rewind was so good too i love ashing because
she was really just like the the soul type a and a group of
type b's oh my god she was hardcore like it was so good
though it was so good though honestly like when we before we
went we thought ashton's plan was going to be like okay down
to the minute down to the millisecond like you have time to
eat this little snack here and then yeah straight to this
ride and then straight to this ride but now it ended up
being like you know more like maybe yeah maybe maybe that's
just because like we're we were all like theme park like
fans.
So like we were all like locked in.
We were like, yeah, we need to ride this ride like right
now.
We can eat later.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like the way that when Animal Kingdom opened and we like, we
were like crazy beeline.
We were like speedwalking like crazy.
We weren't running because you're not allowed to run, but we
were definitely like power walking.
We were power walking to Avatar Ride.
It was crazy.
And then like Ashton would look behind and be like, oh, you
guys are still behind me.
Yeah.
We were, it was kind of, it was kind of nuts.
It was an exercise day.
Imagine, I want everybody to imagine a chinchilla, a mouse,
a ladybug, and a ghost all like through the park.
Like legit, like the power walking stance, like the, stance
that like athletes get just imagine us doing that throughout
the it was so good we were serious man we wanted to ride
that avatar ride we yeah we did we were serious and we did
and i got turned on are you ready to play the game yeah okay
so do you want to proceed with the poop brown color or did
you want to switch i'm okay with any color Okay, okay.
Okay, let me know when to stop.
Randomize, randomize.
Stop.
Blue.
Blue, okay.
It's like the same color as my eyes.
I'm just obsessed with you.
What's going on?
I'm checking the audio for my...
For the game.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, let us know Ibu's and Bug Bros.
Let us know.
Eh, oh, sorry.
I forgot.
Why am I doing that?
You hate me.
Ah, you hate me.
Wait, how do you punch again?
A?
Oh, oh.
Wait, that's no jump for me.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I think you have to be, like, next to me.
Wait, I'm pushing.
No wrong button.
Wait.
Other one?
Oh, there we go.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Get away from me.
Oh, oh, oh.
What?
Oh!
No game audio!
Sorry, guys.
Oops.
Uh-oh.
Shut up.
Whoa!
I didn't even do anything.
What the heck?
Oh, wait, hold on.
I gotta...
Where am I...
Wait, wait, did you... Did you make me go back in?
Oh, my bad.
What the... What the heck?
How did I do that?
Alright.
You did?
Ah!
anyways we're gonna finish this game this is the 49th game
on minto's list it is it is i'm trying to yeah 50 games this
year everybody yeah 50 she's on her way yeah you you knocked
out croak i i gotta i gotta watch the vod but i did not i
really did not expect you you to when you were like do you
have any game recommendations like shorter games i was like
yeah croak country is like pretty short But that took me
like three streams to do.
Three streams.
Yeah, so I was like, I was like, okay, so it's like, it's on
the shorter side.
It's not like DMC or Metal Gear, right?
Right.
But...
I really did not expect you to finish it all in one stream.
What the heck?
It was only seven hours.
I feel like that's a...
Like it's a longer stream, obviously, but it's like
definitely doable for...
No, but you like really locked in, I guess.
I got a...
Did you like it?
I really like the story.
I actually really liked it.
Yeah, right.
The story is like, oh.
Yeah.
And it was very forgiving for, like, survival.
I, like, got a comment of someone being, like, oh, it was
kind of, it was, you know, it was fun to watch Minto play
it, but at the same time, like, her, because I would hoard
bullets, like, I didn't want to use, I didn't want to shoot
very much.
But, like, it's because I'm so traumatized by other games
that they give you, like, two bullets every two hours.
So I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why I had faith.
We're both gamers.
I just ran everywhere.
Whoa, hey.
Hey.
Don't touch me.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
All right.
7-4.
Wait, how many more do we have here?
I think it's literally just this, I think.
And then upstairs?
Yeah, upstairs and then this might be the end like this this
legitimately might be an hour stream no well maybe oh yeah
because we're gamers yeah yeah because we're gamers exactly
oh congratulations on dying she even yelled at me all right
oh it smells like beef stew in here it's making me sick yeah
definitely definitely some some survival horror games are
like way too crazy Hold on.
How do we do this again?
Oh, gosh.
No, you have to throw me.
Remember, it's like a...
Oh, you didn't even give me warning!
Come on, you can make it.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Send me over, Chief.
Okay, I got you.
Nice.
Go die?
Got it.
Now what do I do?
Oh, I guess we just go back.
That's just a setup.
Wait, there's like something here.
I'm lost?
Uh...
Can you...
Huh.
Oh, I'm here.
We beat the level.
Okay, thanks for coming to the stream.
Okay.
What about...
Oh.
Good job.
Hold on.
Thank you.
Oh, I see you there.
Oh.
Yeah, good job.
I was close.
I was closer than you.
Oh!
Yeah, okay.
Closer than me.
All right.
Yeah!
Oh, good job!
I made it.
What happened to you?
Well, listen.
Wait.
I'm gonna try and get the...
Hold on.
Oh.
Oh, you think that's...
No.
It is not a secret.
Oh.
Wait, where is...
Oh, wait, why do I spawn here?
I don't know.
Give me two.
What?
Hello?
Woo!
Oh, how do I use this again?
Wait.
Um, wait.
How...
Oh, God.
Wait, why do I keep falling?
Oh, I see how you get the...
Oops.
I see how you get the...
What's it called?
How you get it?
Yeah, hold on.
I'm going to try.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
You see it?
I see what you're putting down.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
You're so smart.
I did it!
Yeah!
Wait, sorry.
I blocked you?
Okay.
All right.
How do I use this thing again?
You just go.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
So close.
Oh, you killed him.
You killed him.
I did?
Yeah.
Whoa, where am I?
Ah, I was so close.
Where are you?
I don't know.
Why are you all the way up there?
How did this happen?
I'll put this, I'll put this there, though.
Oh, that's, oh, yippee.
Yay, yippee.
Get off.
Sorry.
I'm here.
Um...
No, no, no!
You can say help!
How'd you do that?
It's like one of the trigger buttons.
Oh, that's not it.
That's not it.
There you go.
Help!
No, no, no, no!
You guys, what if I just...
No!
What do we do here, Barry?
You just go back down.
Oh, we do?
We go back down, silly.
And then we go...
We go...
Uh...
Down here, probably?
Oh, we didn't go this way?
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, I don't think so.
Okay.
Oh!
You got this?
Oh.
Oh!
I think my timing is a bit off.
Yeah, yeah, you got this, though.
Yeah, you got it, you got it, you got it!
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, no, no, no, no.
I didn't have it.
Oh!
One hour stream, everybody.
Yeah, every hour after the first hour, every 30 minutes that
passes after the first hour, you can send hate mail.
address jane bezos at amazon.com i got you i'll be sure to
read them all
where am i okay
did you just try to kill me yeah yeah prep them prep them
okay oh shoot ouch come on i like slide but i forgot how to
slide oh why does this keep happening to me how do how do
you slide oh you oh oh not like that don't do that oh oh
don't i don't know how to get rid of it barry i don't feel
like okay wait okay oh no wait wait that's not it oh no no
no no how do you slide no that's oh oh it's a it's a x so
like x x and like that oh oh wait hold on hold on wait it's
like it's like a two thing a two yeah there you go there you
go there you go yeah yeah yeah wait oh okay okay yeah you
gotta be like pressing the the air okay i got you i got you
okay there you go sorry we're we're trying we're trying to
relearn the game oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
You got this, you got this.
No!
Oh, you got this!
Make it!
You have to make it, Barry!
Okay, I'm gonna die.
Alright, yeah, die?
Do you throw yourself right now?
I did?
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Nice, there you go.
Okay, do you have to throw...
Do you throw me or do I throw you off of...
Oh.
Yeah, go.
Oh, shit.
I got it?
I think you have to do that again, but not die.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, I saw you.
Oh, okay, okay, I see, I see it.
Alright, now you can make it.
What if you can't, though?
No, please.
I can't!
I can't make it.
Wait.
Ah!
Now, why would you go and do that?
You know, hold on.
Come back, come back down here, and I'll throw you up.
Okay, okay.
But how do you...
This way.
There you go.
Okay, but how do you...
Okay, maybe...
I think you just got...
Grab my hand.
Ah, okay.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Grab my hand.
Do a handshake event.
Grab my disgusting hand.
Okay, okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm wearing the hazmat suit.
All right.
You throw me up.
Okay, I'll throw you up.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, does that work?
I don't know.
I think I don't, I think so.
Wait, can you jump?
You're so- wait, if I jump?
There you go.
Ah!
Oh!
Wait, you're fine!
You're fine!
I don't know if I can...
I don't think I can.
Oh, you know what?
You probably have to bring the movable thing down here to-
to like platform.
You know what I mean?
Or I go up there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
All right, watch this.
Wow, truly a master.
Oh, what were you saying?
What were you saying?
I wasn't...
All right, watch this.
Oh!
Oh yeah, now it's...
Now the table switch.
There you go, see?
That's how you do it.
I'm gonna curl myself.
Okay, here we go.
You just gotta, you gotta, you gotta kick.
Why does that keep getting?
Oh, whatever.
I don't care anymore, I don't care anymore.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
We made it.
Okay, now what?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Did we get everything?
I think so.
Yeah.
Oh, let me in.
Oh.
.
Clear.
Guys, what was the time on that?
Don't worry about it.
We got an A.
It's true.
All right.
X2 seen 2.
The exit's right here.
Okay, I'm going down.
We gotta collect gems.
Oh, wait.
How do you...
Oh.
How do you hold on?
Oh, I think it's a trigger, right?
Yeah, it's a trigger.
Okay.
Yeah, that happened to me too.
Oh, I did not pay attention.
Look at me.
I'm...
Spider-Man.
Oh my god, you're literally...
I'm on your butt.
Yeah, you're on my booty.
Oh!
Ouch!
Wait, did I do that?
Did I do that?
Who can grab up there?
Oh, man.
Okay.
You got it.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, I tried to grab.
I did not successfully grab.
Oh, okay.
Oh, nice, nice.
What now?
Oh, probably like here.
Oh my god, it's all grabbing.
Oh my god.
Oh, oops.
Wait!
Oh, okay.
I'm fine.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
You got it.
I believe in you.
Do you just hold the trigger?
Will you still?
Yeah, I just hold it.
Oh, why am I down here?
Where are you?
Go up, so go up into the teleporter.
Oh, I see it.
There you go.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry, sorry.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
Yeah, everything's cool.
Alright.
Oh, that's not it.
Sorry, I thought that was still important.
It's okay.
Okay, I think I...
You threw me to my death?
Alright, here I go.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, there you go.
Okay.
Don't, don't, don't, okay.
Alright.
Now what?
Go up there?
I guess, I guess we continue.
Yeah.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh!
There's a thing there!
Oh, that worked out.
That worked out.
That's fine.
Oh.
Oh, come on.
There we go.
There you go.
Yippee!
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
There's probably a secret.
Oh, watch out.
Wait.
Like, to get to the thing?
Oh, wait, no.
It's probably like we need to do a switch first.
you think so hold on i think so
wait this is hell okay oh oh damn it ah so close oh okay
okay you got it i got it we're fine everything's cool yeah
you got it you got it you got it
Get you!
Oh, wait, I went into the clouds there.
Yeah, I don't, mmm.
The switch is probably down here.
Oh, somewhere.
Somewhere.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, stop, stop, stop.
You killed him.
Good job?
Yeah.
You murdered him.
I love the kill.
Oh, and then we do this!
Oh!
Oh, and then we redo the whole level.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, get him!
Yeah, nice.
And then we redo the whole level.
I love that.
I watched that happen.
Before my very eyes.
That didn't help you at all.
Wait, so you get out of there like this.
Or no.
Where we go back the opposite.
The same.
Yeah, we probably go up.
Oh, that's a lot of cats.
Kill him.
Yeah.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
Okay, we got him.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, wait, there we go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I think you have to do that on your own.
Okay.
There you go.
Go, go, go.
Very good.
And we go back over here.
Oh.
All right.
We do this hellscape again.
Oh, wait, there's so- Oh my God.
Ah!
Okay.
You got it.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Now we have to...
Let's go up.
Alright.
You got that.
Yeah.
Easy peasy.
Okay.
And then...
Nice.
Ah!
No!
I had it.
It's okay.
You let me respawn close to you.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
See this?
I'll go.
And then...
Help!
Um...
You put on the thing!
Help!
Wait, stand on it real quick?
Stand on yours?
Oh.
Now, get off of it.
I sacrificed- Oh, wait.
Wait, this is so bad.
The cursor's on the screen.
Go again?
Oh, it is.
You good?
Sorry.
My cursor was on the screen even though it wasn't on the
game.
It's okay, that's the true, like, game experience.
Like, old game series.
Oh, wait, why'd you do that?
Oh!
I didn't do...
Oh, man.
Okay.
Oh!
There we go.
Oh, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Wait, how do we get back inside?
Oh, just kidding.
We just walk through.
Yeah, we just walk.
Oh, and then this is the final...
All right.
How do we...
Jump.
And then jump.
Oh.
Oh, you could just...
Okay, there you go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ow, no!
Stand on my body.
I did.
I used your body.
Use my body.
Okay.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
Wait, how do you get...
Now what?
Oh, try it.
That's it.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, it was not spawned yet.
It's okay.
I will wait for you.
I'll wait for you.
Yeah.
You got it.
We have all the time in the world.
This is one hour max.
so I'm not I'm not losing on purpose everybody don't worry
oh yeah she's just taking her sweet time yeah of course yeah
I'm actually like still trying to remember how to do this
damn game oh my god you want me to end it end my suffering
okay there you go you made it yeah she's manipulating RNG
she's she's It's you want to understand it's it's
speedrunner stuff This is like the most advanced tactics
that speedrunners can do that they that they die in every
single possible way so that they can See exactly where they
need to go to in yeah, yeah, they're setting up.
They're setting up.
You want to understand because you're not gamers like we
are.
Yeah, okay.
What?
I don't think I'm here.
I'm here.
Yeah, you're there.
I'm there.
Okay.
That's the end.
Where's the end?
Below?
Oh, yeah, I see it.
Whoa!
Okay, I made it.
You made it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, whoa.
You're making it.
But I need your help.
I need your help.
I'm coming.
Ah!
Survive!
Okay, go!
No!
Oh!
Oh, oh my god.
Come here!
You have to be at the end.
There we go.
Be careful?
Climb there, yeah.
What is this?
Oh!
Okay, well.
Uh...
Yeah, I was gonna say you will probably...
Wait.
Oh, you probably have to...
Oh, no, that wasn't good.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
Okay, yeah.
You jump?
Wait, let me...
Or be on the ladder.
Be on the ladder.
Yeah, that's what I was gonna say.
Okay.
There you go.
There we go.
Yeah, you can jump!
Oh, sorry!
Why would you do that?
And now I need you to jump.
jump again?
Okay.
There you go.
And then, I will not jump.
My fingers are off the controller.
Okay.
Now, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Got it.
Oh, got it.
Oh, yep.
I got it.
I got a jet pack and I don't know why.
You're so insecure.
I don't know what this does.
Oh, oh, what is it?
Oh.
No!
There's another jemmy.
Oh, there is another jemmy.
Here, I'll go get it.
I'll go get it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I got this.
I don't know what this does.
It doesn't even do anything.
No!
I don't know if that's something you can get.
I don't know either.
Oh!
Never mind.
You totally got it?
Wait, there's also a boat up there though.
There's a boat, yeah.
I think we have to do this.
Oh, I think we have to like jetpack through the death area.
Oh!
I think you're right.
I think so.
We have the flappy bird.
Oh my god.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, here.
Oh, you made it.
You made it.
Yeah, you gotta make it now.
You gotta make it.
You got it?
Oh, nice.
I made it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh.
Yeah.
Oh, do that.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
You got that?
Yeah, there.
I don't think I can.
Wait.
Oh, you got it.
Oh, there we go.
You got it.
Thank you.
Yeah, nice.
I push it.
Yeah, you just have to push it.
And I fall.
Wee!
All right!
Yippee!
Yay!
There's a Kappa.
What does this guy do again?
I can't...
I don't remember.
Open.
Oh.
Uh oh.
He doesn't hurt us though.
I do remember that.
You don't...
Oh!
That's where he launches us.
Yeah, he launches us.
But there's another gemmy.
Oh no!
He died!
I think you might have to get the gemmy.
I don't know how.
I didn't even get it.
How do I get it?
Oh, maybe I have to throw you over.
Hold on.
Oh, wow.
I think I have to throw you over.
There's spikes right there.
That's crazy.
Hold on.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh, no.
We gotta wait for him to die, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Now?
Wait, oh, let me come back.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Wait, no.
I got it.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
You got it.
Oops.
Oh.
Okay.
Eat me.
Help me.
teleport to you okay no actually no this is good this is
good poop me okay poop me poop me poop me what is this oh
it's like that looks out wait is this a secret down here oh
no it's not but you're that seemed like one i know it seems
like it right where do i go oh oh there we go I'm going to
go up here.
Out.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, there we go.
Now it's time to game.
Oh, God.
Okay, good luck.
Good luck, everybody.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh.
Wait, there's too much going on.
My brain!
Ah!
Oh, please.
Oh, there's a yarn there.
Oh, okay.
Okay, take your time.
Okay.
Take your time.
Alright.
Oh, nice!
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Okay.
Yeah, you see what I'm putting down.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot!
Okay, there you go.
Oh, you got it?
Oh, no.
Oh, okay, okay.
How do we?
Um, I think you got a...
Uh...
Oh, there we go!
But what's up?
How do we get up there up to the very tippy top?
Well, there is a...
Oh, there's a ladder.
Oh, it does.
Maybe...
I think there is.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We just have to...
Oh!
I beeped it.
The very last moment.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're speed running.
We're speed running?
Yeah.
Please.
Give me the block.
Ah!
Shit.
There's so much going on.
I mean, you're like...
Stop sending me to the other side!
Guys, you have to understand.
We're like...
froze but we're like the faker of battle block theater so
we're actually like really good i mean if we're struggling
this much imagine how much you guys would struggle oh dang
it
patty is yelling at me and it's it's it's distressing me
right now oh you got it nice that means that means we both
got it we both got it there we go i guess you don't need a
duck
Yeah, we're showing you guys what not to do.
No, we've just showed them how to clear the level.
That's true, that's true.
Wait, we missed one.
No, that one's like a super secret one only the devs know
about.
Oh, they put it in there.
Actually, it's a red herring.
It never existed at all.
Yeah, yeah, it's true.
It's true.
They say that there is an extra one, but they just are
trying to make you go mad.
Yeah.
What is that air conditioning?
I know, it's so loud.
Oh.
Oh, hello.
Oh, you're all the way up there.
Yeah.
Me too.
Wait, what's this one?
Okay.
You want to go this way first?
Oh, I was just going to split up and conquer, divide it.
Oh, I guess we could.
Wow, you totally honed that.
That's fine.
I left a little bit of the ladder to give to you.
I don't think we can.
I think you have to launch.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, your body.
Oh, oh, my body.
Go down.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
All right.
We got this.
Okay.
You launch me.
Oh, okay.
You get ready?
Oh, I'm sorry.
All right.
Let me...
Oh, I think I have to be closer to the...
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, that worked out.
I don't know what this does.
Um...
I'm going down.
Wait.
I think I'm stuck here.
Wait, no, I'm not.
No, you're good.
Okay.
I've never been better.
I mean, there's like a big mirror.
I'll launch you over here.
Wait, hold on.
Oh.
Can I not?
Oh, I guess not.
What does that do though?
It opens up so that we can go downstairs.
Launch me.
Okay.
We're down the ladder.
I'm still in a dream.
What a thrill.
Oh, are you gonna?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Oh, I took them both.
Well, where does this...
It's okay.
How do I need to go here?
Can we do this, like, out of border?
What's going on?
Ouch.
Aw, man.
Wait, why am I here?
Wait, where did you go?
I'm going...
I'm down here.
Okay, I'll go down there.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Oh.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, oops.
Oh, goodbye.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's tricky.
It's really hard.
Oh, wait, here.
Let me...
I'm gonna, I'll stop out here.
Stand?
Yeah, if you stand there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, stop.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
One second.
I'll get it.
Don't worry.
You got it?
I got this.
You got this.
Oops.
There you go.
Oh, oh.
It's okay.
Maybe stand.
Maybe try and like, yeah, maybe the...
Like follow you?
Oops.
I'll just be like here so that I like constantly...
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm like a Koopa.
Oh, my gosh.
I didn't even press it then.
Oh, oops.
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Let me grab another one.
I'm like trying to get the sweet spot of pressing it and not
pressing it.
Sometimes I just don't press it.
Oops.
Sometimes I press it too early.
Oh, sometimes I don't press it.
Oh, oh, it's okay.
Sometimes I press it too early.
Sometimes I don't press it.
Sometimes you just push it.
Oh, there you go.
I got you.
Wait, okay, stay on that maybe.
Now I'm stuck.
I don't know.
Oh, oh, my thing ran out.
Yeah, get it?
Grab it?
Yeah.
What did that do?
What did my button do?
I have no clue.
I don't think I need to stay on this, though, do I?
What does that do?
I don't think I need to stay on it.
Maybe not.
Okay, let's go here.
So that clears up the thingy.
I think we have to just keep clearing the level.
No, no, no, no.
Don't put it on one end.
No?
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
And here, here, too, too, too.
Okay, okay.
There you go then.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
All right, we need to slide here.
Careful.
Nice.
Okay, what did that do?
Oh, I was so close.
Oh, nice.
Wait, turn it off?
Okay.
Uh, you gotta turn it off.
Oh, the other one, I gotta turn it off.
Yeah, it's okay, it's okay.
Okay, it's turned off now, okay.
Okay, okay.
Then you can go over here, maybe?
Do you trust me?
Take my hand if you trust me.
Oh my goodness, great!
Wait, let me get up there first.
Maybe you don't have to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
the guy you gotta grab yeah yeah yeah the ladder oh I think
you need the top I think you need the top one oh but it
breaks it or maybe oh no no no you're good yeah yeah yeah
but how what do you do from here oh yeah from here um I
don't know if there's a way to I don't think so I'm gonna go
towards where we turned off the fans Okay, okay.
Wait, maybe you can.
How do we...
How the heck?
Oh, wait, wait, no, I made it!
Oh, you made it!
She's a gamer, you guys.
She's an absolute gamer.
Wait, okay.
Oh, hello.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god, why can't I reach it?
Oh.
Wait, why don't we spawn over there?
It's okay.
We'll make it.
Okay.
Just give me a second.
I'll make it.
Ah!
Oh my god!
It's kind of tough.
Okay.
You get it every time though.
It's me, I'm the issue.
No man, it's because I've perfected my method.
What the fuck?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no!
No!
No, no, no, no, don't worry!
I don't need to prove anything.
I want to do it!
I'm so angry right now, everybody.
Why?
You got it, you got it, you got it.
You have to do it, Vince.
You have to.
Oh my gosh, now I can't even actually get up here.
Oh my god.
Wait.
No, you just go on this line.
You just go on this line.
constantly I know but wait which which way do you just spam
it just spam it I am oh there we go there you go oh I
feel like oh wait we were here before yeah wait oh and then
and then we do this oh okay wait they're here oh you got it
oh yeah what is this guy oh wait Can I ride this guy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Okay, okay, hold on.
Drop me, drop me.
I'm dropping it?
Okay.
Okay, now what?
I don't know.
Oh, wait, there's so many down there.
Look at all of them.
Can you, can you, like, bring it over here, maybe?
Or is he just stuck there?
Oh, wait, wait, let me get on your head.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait.
I don't know if this is the right way.
Wait, I don't think it's the other way.
Yeah.
Like, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, wait, and you leave him on the...
on the thingy.
What?
Maybe?
This thing?
The button?
Yeah.
I don't know what that does, but that definitely does.
We have to turn those off.
I don't think we can...
Wait, I think we just... I think I just screwed that up.
No, no, I think it's fine.
I think that's what they wanted, maybe.
I don't think so.
Because... Oh.
And then we go back up here.
Maybe.
Oh!
What is it?
We go back up Oh, wait, no.
We gotta get back.
Oh, wait.
Where's the teleporter?
It's, um...
Oh, it's up there.
It's up there.
Yeah.
And the only way to go back up there is to go here.
We have to go back up.
No, this is not.
Yeah, because if you see, uh, we got the green.
guy.
Oh, wait, here.
You can prove your... You can prove your...
I can do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You got this.
Okay, here we go, everybody.
You got it.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now what do I do?
Now you gotta space out your jumps really well because you
gotta make it to this ladder.
Oh, why would I do that?
Oh.
Why would they do that?
Why would John Battle Blossom do that?
Wait, I'm gonna make it, don't worry.
You got it, you got it.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
All right.
I got it.
There you go.
There you go, isn't it?
Okay.
And then go up here.
Oh, you can use my body.
Oh, it's gone now.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Because now we have...
That wasn't that far.
We need to get rid of the yellow...
I mean, not yellow, the white...
Oh, but was there a button for it?
Was there a button for it?
Oh, that's where the cat is.
But where is...
Oh, but we also need...
Oh, I see it.
We...
Okay, so basically down here are the things that we put
the...
The rocks.
Yeah, the rocks.
But how do we...
What activates them, though?
What's the button?
it's where the cat is but how do we get oh i see oh we need
to use the air conditioners to kill the cat
like to the cat to direct the the grenade to direct the
bombs yeah yeah yeah okay this one's so complicated oh my
god it is it is very complicated wait so how do we get there
Okay, how do we get, yeah, how do we get there again?
I think we have to go this way again.
Oh, shoot.
I did not realize that was water.
It's okay.
Okay.
What is this one doing?
Oh no, I mistimed it.
Yeah, it's grape soda.
Oh, and then we use this.
I wore a load of grapes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, this one.
Oh.
you got it you got it oh my god getting it back over there
is crazy okay okay oh oops oh oh okay oh what now okay we're
fine oh okay somehow do you just make it down no down is not
the i think you just have to turn on the last one yeah oh oh
great you did it oh my god first try okay yeah you did it
okay that's that's the thing you needed to do and then now
We have to go back up.
We have to go back over there.
Okay.
Oh my god.
We have to go all the way back up.
I think so.
Wait, how do we get in there, though?
That's the thing.
What do you mean?
Oh no, we don't go in there anymore.
Oh, oh, I see.
It broke the block.
Okay, I get it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it broke the thing.
Okay, so now.
Ah!
Now!
Oh my god.
We...
Okay, those just dropped.
Okay.
So now, yeah.
Well, I'm just gonna explode to get by you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, there we go.
And then this also opened up.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what a fucking crazy level.
How the hell did you figure that out?
What the hell?
My brain hurts.
I know.
Dude, the people who make levels like these are crazy.
And you solved it.
Oh, we can play a puzzle game and really just die.
Oh, it calls him.
It calls him.
Wait.
Oh, wait, oh, what do you...
Oh, I guess you just have to...
Ah!
My speed!
Oh.
Bruh!
Oh, I see him, though.
Oh, sorry.
Ah, my speed!
It calls back both of them.
That's crazy.
Yeah, it's okay.
Just don't die.
Okay, that one you can use.
Oh, ah, no!
Okay.
Maybe we should go at one at a time.
Oh, wait.
It's LT to hold on, isn't it?
Sorry.
It's RT to hold on.
Yeah, I think.
Oh, whoops.
Okay, you know what?
Because I've fucked up so many times, I didn't want to use
this as a crutch, but I literally have had a migraine all
day, you guys.
So, uh...
No!
I'm using it as my crutch now.
Guys, it's not her fault.
She has a freaking migraine.
night and it hasn't gone away really oh yeah i blame crow
country wait why are they leaving me
okay little guys all right let them block it okay okay oh
you got it you got it okay all right why did he do that what
happened why did he move why did he do that he hate you wait
i have to What was that?
I don't know!
Oh, wait.
Alright.
Is this a secret?
Oh, wait.
No, it's not.
Okay.
Is that not a secret?
You can go, oh, I see it.
Probably, no.
Or it's from...
No, it doesn't seem like it.
Okay.
Okay, it literally hates me.
Wait, why did he room again?
He literally hates me, though.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
I'm coming.
I'm on my way.
Is this a secret?
Where is a secret?
It has to be somewhere, right?
Um...
Maybe...
Oh, hold on.
Maybe it's...
crawling in this way.
No?
I think it's from top.
Yeah, maybe.
Ah!
Okay.
Here I go.
Yeah, you got it.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, there's a second fan!
There's a second fan blowing you back.
Oh, I see.
So you're right at the middle.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
Go, go.
All right, I'll go next.
Okay.
Oh, why did you do this?
I'm gonna kill you.
No, why?
Why?
I didn't even do that.
Oh, wait, why did I?
Oh, I died in my own bubble.
that was dangerous a little bit yeah no i don't think so oh
oh no the the guy okay wait how do you oh no it's a puzzle
oh this is a nightmare oh you got it this oh this is a
nightmare we sound so icky wait uh wait what oh shoot oh oh
oh oh okay i'm gonna trap myself in here okay does that does
that do anything maybe you can drag down.
I've trapped myself.
Wait, let me try.
You got it?
Okay, there you go.
And then do it again one more time, maybe?
There we go.
I'm doing it.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh, I'm standing somehow.
I don't know how.
Wait.
Wait, no.
Oh, wait.
Let me push this one.
To do that.
Okay, nice.
There we go.
Okay.
And drag that one down.
Okay, nice.
And then drag this one down.
and then push this one over and then oh okay there you go um
yeah i guess i could just die
oh and it'll push you down yeah this is so comfy this is so
comfy yay oh hit berry bug hit berry bug
That was crazy!
Let's just go over there, man.
Oh, thank you.
I don't know if I can make that.
Yeah, you gotta...
Oh, whoopsie.
Okay.
Here I come, here I come!
Oh, woohoo!
Okay, nice.
Then...
There's a...
I'll just like... Oh my god, sorry.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh, you probably have to go to the teleporter.
Oh, no, never mind.
There you go.
Oh, I wasn't close enough.
Bye, bud.
It's okay.
Hey, wait a minute.
Ah, damn it.
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, don't you dare.
Wait, why did I go backwards?
I don't know.
Thank God.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, We died together!
We died...
You didn't die that time.
We died together!
Oh, we died together for you.
We died...
Oh, shoot.
Thanks for getting that.
Oh, I didn't see that was there.
We died together!
Okay, now this goes...
Okay, you're right.
I do think...
Wait, what is this?
Oh, what?
Okay.
Wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo.
Wait, one more time?
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Okay, he's angry.
Oh, he's gonna be released!
Ah!
You hate me.
Wait, um...
What's the- Oh, so now it's on the green blocks.
Oh, you got this?
Uh, I'm gonna try- Woo!
Wait, you might have to launch me or you launch me.
Okay, okay, that didn't work.
No, it didn't at all.
Or actually go on the ladder, go on the...
Oh yeah, yeah, use my head, use my head.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, there we go.
Alright.
Get the...
There you go.
Okay, there you go.
Very nice.
Oh shit, he's jumping!
How do we get away from this guy?
I don't, I guess like, maybe one of us just has to be a
sacrifice.
Oh, I'm next.
I'm next, baby.
I'm next.
No, no, no.
Oh, my bad.
Save yourself!
Thank you, save yourself!
Oh my god.
Mmm, yummy.
Okay.
Tasty, guys.
We have to redo this entire thing.
But the other way around.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, there we go.
You got it.
Oh, oh, oh.
I don't need your hands.
Oh, whatever.
Oh, shoot.
I might need you.
Yeah, now you need me.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, oh.
One more time.
Maybe you should just...
Maybe you just go on my head.
Think about the avatar, Rod.
Why did someone say that?
Why did you say that?
Why did you say it like that?
I need you to hold...
Oh, wait.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, we're good.
And then we go this way.
We go this way.
And then we go...
Launch.
I'll launch you.
Okay, thank you.
And then...
There you go.
Okay.
Oh no, we have to redo all of this too.
Wait.
We kind of borked it.
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Okay, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then...
Oh, oh, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, wait, this one.
Oh, this one.
Oh, stop.
No, no, no, move the other one.
Move the other one.
I'm trying to every time I face this way.
No, not that one.
I don't know why it's doing that look at that I don't know
why I'm trying to grab this one on the right get out of the
hole get out of the hole what is happening I'll do it why
didn't it let me you saw that what the hell I guess I just
have the charm I just have oops oh oh oh oh oh oh whoa why
is it it like put me back right there it's crazy i don't
know it has to be a secret right yeah because we saw the
yarn oh no not that
why is she she's so evil oh damn oh wait oh wait we have our
guys we have to call them yeah oh why are you going on the
way there you idiots they hate us yeah okay you got it oh
you're a pro at this now nice wait but how do we okay still
though oh is it is it here what is that what is it where
where is that is it the plus right here try the i don't know
oh no it's not the No, no, no.
It was above.
Well, whatever.
We don't need it.
Yeah, who cares?
We're done.
Who gives a poof?
There we go.
Yeah!
Now you guys know it's not those two blocks.
You gotta go up.
Yeah!
This is a playthrough for your...
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Okay, this is the last level before the final idea.
No, I think there's two more, no?
Or one more?
One more door?
Nope.
There is one more door, but this is the last one before that
door, I think.
We have a friend that is trapped.
He's 12.
Come here!
Pew!
Take my hand, pink fellow.
Take my hand.
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
Take my hand.
I love you more.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, take my hand.
My hand is not...
My hand's cleaner.
I washed it.
Berrybug does not wash your hands.
I do wash my hands.
Damn it.
Take my head.
Oh, we're back at the beginning.
Wait, there's a teleporter here.
Oh.
Wait, oh, we can't do that.
Oh, dang.
Okay, we can't do that yet.
Mental note of that.
Mental note.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
I'm hard.
Wait, what does this do?
Oh, it launches me?
Okay.
Um...
And then I guess...
Oh!
Ew!
Oh, that's messed up.
I got it though?
Oh, look at him.
I turned it off.
Oh.
Ouchie, ouch.
Kill his ass!
Oh, whoa, whoa.
How did I get down there?
There you go.
There's a second one.
Oh, I just realized.
Yeah, there's there's multiple.
It's messed up.
Okay, now what?
Wait, but there's a...
He's on something.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
What?
And then...
Oh, I think that's if you mess it up.
Right?
Oh, you're right.
Oh, maybe I need to come back or...
And grab it.
Can you...
If you throw it...
Maybe?
Can you throw it above the clouds or...
Oh, no.
Okay, hold on.
Maybe...
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Wait.
I don't think I can.
I think we need the green blocks to disappear.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I think you're right.
We'll just let it keep doing that.
We have that emotion.
Yeah, we have that emotion, exactly.
We'll just let it do its thing there.
Oh, what is this?
you're fine oh nice dodge oh okay okay you got it i killed
him oh oh oh yeah i mean it's okay yeah yeah all right oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh okay let me go again you maybe you should
do it never here okay okay okay okay okay i i got you
oh no wait how do we keep the green gone oh Oh, wait, you're
right.
Uh...
I mean, maybe we just need this for now, and then...
Yeah, I don't know.
Uh...
Oh, how did he get over there?
Get out of here, man.
Oh, you got him.
You think...
Should I stay on that, you think?
And you want to...
That's what I was thinking, honestly, like...
You can't make your way back without...
Oh, no, there's a boulder now.
Oh, there's another...
There's another trigger.
Okay, I see it.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Just kill him!
Kill him!
Ah.
Okay, don't like...
Oh, they're kind of nice.
They're, they, like...
They, like, puddle you.
Oh my god.
Wait, they're not nice.
They're not nice.
Oh, oh, we killed him.
We're fine.
Okay, okay, we're good.
Alright, wait a second though.
Wait, come back though.
Come back.
We gotta go back up there.
Why?
Because there's a jemmy.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
You gotta be on my head, or I gotta be on your head.
There you go.
Jump him.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, nice.
Okay, sis.
We gave him the gift of sweet release.
Oh, it made it in there.
Okay, nice.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Now...
Now our friend is been ejected.
Oh, he's free.
He's free, yeah.
He's free.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
There's probably a secret here.
Hold on.
What do I do with it?
Oh, wait.
Wait, what do I do with him?
I think you just cried to get him through the teleporter.
Or maybe not.
He doesn't follow me.
Oh, yes, he does.
Oh, no, he does.
I need your help.
Wait, there's a ball.
I'm all here!
Oh, I see it.
Oh, but there's a gemmy here at the bottom.
Oh, it's okay.
I'll make it.
Oh, shit.
Oh wait, hold on.
Hold on.
How do I...
Do you need me to come up?
Wait, there you go.
Oh, you got it.
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Wait, there's definitely a secret in there, don't you think?
You think so?
It's okay.
Whatever.
Like maybe a hidden gem.
Okay, what do you need me for?
I need your head to go down over there to the other side.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, oops.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, wait.
I can't get through.
He's...
Oh, what are you shooting for then?
What do you need him for?
So we...
Oh, I don't know, actually.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no, no.
You do that thing.
Yeah, do that thing.
Ah, I see.
And...
Oh Drop him Oh yeah because he needs to go into the water Oh
there you go You want me to go up there and see if there was
a hidden thing Yeah yeah yeah you got it Oh you need to save
your jetpack fuel Oh You need to just like do single jumps
the entire Well you do one here to get out And then you do
single jumps the entire The rest of the way up Okay You got
it, you got it, you got it And then up Oh okay go on the
slide you're fine no i'm not are you sure there's something
secret up there well maybe there's not you think we have all
the gems we have six gems that might be all of them maybe
what do you guys think what your answers down below comment
how many gems there were in this level i'm coming it's okay
we just go we just go we oh what hello hello hello I think
there were six.
Don't say it.
Oh, there were seven.
Yeah, there might have been six or seven.
Don't say it.
Why would you say that?
Don't do it.
Don't give it.
What do you mean?
It's just numbers.
Oh, wait, you are right.
That was the last one.
Yeah.
Wait, what about these, though?
Those are, like, the secret harder ones.
That we don't have to do.
We got six out of another number.
You can say, what did seven ever do to you, man?
Seven killed my mom.
Seven, eight, nine?
You killed your mom.
Oh, no, I forgot these are like the super ultra speed runs.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Hold on.
Okay, oh, I get, we can split.
Oh, we're totally split right now.
It's okay, it's okay.
Okay, we'll go this way.
Ah!
Go, go, go, go, ah!
Oh my god, wait, you kind of threaded that needle.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, let's talk!
Oh god.
Oh God.
Oh God, oh God.
What the hell?
I'm going this way.
Oh my god.
I know there's a way.
I'll follow you.
Oh, it's good.
Oh, it's okay.
Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, I got one, though!
You got one?
Yeah.
Oh, there's another one right there.
What is it?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I got it.
Okay.
Is there anything else over there?
up.
I have no clue.
Okay, cool.
That's fine.
I got you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, watch out.
Ouch!
Wait, there's a thing up here.
What is this for?
Is this?
Oh.
Oh, try, yeah, flicking it over there.
There you go.
Nice, nice.
Nice!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, you made it.
Oh, I need a help here.
No, you don't.
I got it.
Okay, okay, you got it.
You got it.
Oh, you, you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait, what the heck There's a UFO!
He's like...
Um, okay.
Oh, I can't hurt him.
Oh, my God.
He's kind of annoying.
He is really...
He's trying...
He's like breaking the things.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
Nice!
That's okay, that's okay, that's okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm coming to you.
No, I'm not.
Never mind.
Okay, I'll make it there somehow.
Keep going, keep going!
Wait, but there's...
There might be a secret there.
I see.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, shoot.
I got it, I got it.
I got something though.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, oh, God,
oh, God.
Oh, God, oh, oh, God, oh, oh, oh, God, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh.
I don't know how to get out of here.
Oh my gosh, you can't ride the UFO.
That's so lame.
He's body blocking me.
I know.
That's what he does.
Oh, my gosh.
Use my head.
Go on without me!
This is my head!
Uh-oh.
This is the worst thing ever.
This is the worst ever.
Oh my god, I can't freaking get anywhere!
Because they are all exploding!
I made it!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice!
Ah!
Oh.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, no, no, no, no, no!
Maybe nice?
Wait, but he's like right...
Yeah, he's right there.
Okay, keep going, keep going.
I'll explode to you.
I'm running.
Yeah, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Whoops, sorry.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, I killed him.
I killed that guy there.
Okay.
Whoa.
Wait, there's another checkpoint right here.
I got it.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, we only have 30 seconds.
We might not make it.
Okay, we just have to... Where's the exit anyway?
Ouch.
Oh, I was trying to kill him.
Where are you?
Yeah, just go down.
Go down.
Got it.
Yeah, nice.
Yeah, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, ah, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, that dude.
I don't know.
Oh, there's something happening.
there's a bunch of wings okay okay okay oh god oh god oh god
oh god
oh my god oh my god this is oh god oh my god this is
terrible this is so terrible oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay go go go go
okay actually we should oh yeah okay nice nice nice and then
and then you go up there okay nice i'll i'll i'll kill
myself okay it's time to in this part is insanity.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
If anything would work in the...
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Oh, use my head!
Use my head!
Stop!
He destroys them!
He destroys them.
Use my head!
Okay.
Oh my god.
They die so...
They explode so easily.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, we have to...
Wait, I think we need to get out of here.
Oh, you think so?
We're stuck in here, though.
I know, we are...
I can't get the...
Oh my god, this area is so evil, like, actually.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god, okay.
You wanna go...
You go first.
I don't know, I think you should go.
You're the better gamer!
No, no, no, I think I should.
Wait, it's okay, it's okay!
I'm punching him!
Wait.
Go, go, go!
No!
We can kill him!
Kill him!
Oh no, shoot!
Wait, you're gonna go!
crack though yeah he's like dying he's dying for real oh my
god oh my god yes yes wait this is good this is good i made
it nice okay you got it you got it okay i'm getting i got it
i got it i got it okay okay i died i'm coming over i'm
coming over uh watch out oh oh wait we need him to move
though we need him to move come over here okay oh shoot okay
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
Okay.
Okay, nice.
All right.
Okay.
I was gonna kill him.
I'm thinking I'm gonna kill that guy.
No!
Oh my god.
Okay.
There you go.
Now I can kill him.
Oh shoot.
Oh.
There you go.
Okay.
He's dead.
Oh.
Oh god.
Wait, oh wait, I'm trying to kill him, I'm trying to kill
him.
I'm sorry, I keep spawning on your head.
Okay, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh god.
Okay, there he goes.
Death, wait.
Oh my god, no way.
No way.
No way that missed.
Okay, I'm just gonna move on.
Yeah, just go.
Just go, we don't need them.
We don't need them.
Okay.
Oops.
There you go.
And then...
Oh, this one.
There you go.
Okay.
And then we go this way.
Up.
There is a shrimp here.
There's, like, a secret level, but I don't know if we want
to mess around with it.
We kind of...
Oh, Barry, I hate it.
I hate it.
I hate this level.
Oh, okay.
Good job.
Okay, there we go.
How the...
Okay, what is this now?
Um...
How do we...
Oh, I guess we might have to bring the rock over.
Yeah, I think so.
Okay, I brought... The rock is over.
Okay, go over.
And put it in there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Then you need it.
Okay, you're good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's okay!
I'm coming!
Okay, okay.
You can do it!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
I made it.
Yeah, you got it.
Okay.
Alright.
We're through.
Oh god.
Okay.
We're through.
Nice.
There's a guy with the gem.
Oh.
It's okay.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh.
Get him out of here.
Okay.
You got him?
Nice.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Whatever.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay.
If I could kill him, too.
Wait, start...
Oh, shoot.
Okay, there's a...
I think...
Is that a fan?
Get out of here.
Ouchie.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
There's a fan or something somewhere.
Oh, yeah.
There's a guy at the top.
Okay, I thought it was a man.
No, stick him away.
Oh, my God.
Okay, you got...
Oh!
Oh, my God.
This is crazy!
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Oh my god!
Oh they come back down!
They come back down!
Oh my god.
No!
What are you doing?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh yeah, that's the same.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ah!
I was so close!
Oh my god.
Ah no!
Okay.
Ah!
Got it.
Okay.
You got it.
Holy cow.
What is this?
Oh!
Ah!
It releases them!
Oh!
Sorry if I'm hitting you.
It's okay, it's okay.
There's a key here!
There's a big ol' key!
A key?
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god!
Oh my god, how did that not hit you?
How did that not hit you?
You motherfucker.
How?
Get him!
I got the... I got the...
I got the...
Okay, that's all we needed.
That's all we needed.
Oh, there is a key.
Wait, can you step on that?
Can you step on that?
Step on what?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This?
The red...
Oh, here.
I would step on it.
Oh, I see.
No!
Oh, my God!
Hell yeah.
Look at us.
That was easy, dude.
That one wasn't so bad.
This game's so easy, man.
This game's so easy.
Okay, maybe we can do the hardest.
I admire your tenacity.
Oh, is there more?
Oh, oh.
For sure.
But things have really gotten out of control here.
all quickly gone from precocious lovable scamps to
problematic liabilities how ridiculous are we trying to say
people on this twisted island or perhaps we're the crazy
ones and they're all sane what a twist that would be a twist
no that's impossible these guys are bad poop crazy we gotta
get the haddy asap as soon as beer home like a bullet mega
supery fast but you gotta get through that vault and get
that key oh we need to go to a vault is more dangerous than
telling a girl Wait, that's in now, it's crazy.
You're gonna be killed until you're dead but, you know?
Put your big girl panties on.
Everybody has problems.
Yeah, put your big girl panties on.
Put your big girl panties on...
Put your big girl panties on.
Put your big girl panties on!
Their spirits have grown far too weary in children.
Wait, that looks like you guys!
It's an Iwoo!
Rich, buttery sustenance!
Is a slaughter-y sustenance?
You guys eat buns, ?
Buttery sustenance?
By killing Hattie and starting this insanity all over again.
Iwoo, don't drink the butter!
What a counterproductive-y-sauce!
You guys drink butter?
When will they shatter their shackles of ignorance?
Don't drink the butter!
The butter!
When will they stop being stupid, crazy, dumb jerks?
Everyone's kind of sick of it.
But I guess there's no reasoning with madness.
Or cats, for that matter.
Seriously, try talking sense into a cat.
They just stare at you with their life.
It's so true.
It's true.
It looks like Pikachu.
Wait, the guy is pointing at you, baby.
Oh, he was!
I guess.
So are you ready for the most importantly important mission
of your entire life?
Okay, now we lock it.
It's time to show these guys.
They picked the wrong boat of friends to tangle me.
If you just hold on a little longer, homie, we're coming for
you.
It'd be nice if you could meet us halfway, but, you know,
whatever.
We're gonna save you, Hattie.
Are we?
Do we care about this guy?
We are.
Oh, my controller DC'd.
Hold on.
I'm going to...
gone on without you.
Don't say that.
Okay, okay, we're good.
Berrybug has a venomous issue.
Oh, I do.
Oh, wait, oh, these go!
Wait, we didn't do the gotcha yet.
Oh, so true!
Wait, where is it?
Oh, wait, maybe this is just the level start.
That's Hattie!
That's the Hattie!
He's in there!
My big head is blocking him.
That's a big level behind.
Oh, this does seem like the final part.
Oh my gosh.
Look at this.
Metal Gear.
Oh, no shop?
There's got to be a shop.
Oh, stop.
There you go.
Oh, well, I guess you don't really need to go down or up
there, huh?
Yeah, yeah.
There's no shop, but really?
You're going to...
Yeah, do you want to go back to the other place to get the
shop?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go back.
Yeah, we got to do our gambles.
I can't play without my gambling.
Yeah, what the heck?
Play and go in.
today's recent today's modern gamer loves gotcha and that's
all they know wait that's the wrong way no isn't there's one
in here oh there is i think so oh i'm wrong i'm not maybe
maybe i'm wrong i don't know you might be right i'm pretty
sure there was a store in here was there maybe i missed
We're gambling, we're gambling.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, good job.
Come on.
All right.
Let's go.
Hattie, we'll get you out there once we finish.
We'll get you out, Hattie.
All right.
What are you going to, are you going to spin?
Yep.
Triangle, man.
Triangle.
Oh, cute.
That one's cute.
Oh, dinosaur.
Dinosaur.
That looks like the iguana don.
Oh, I, no, it does not.
Kind of did.
No.
Not really.
Oh, whoopsies.
I meant to go here.
Yeah.
And roll in the circle.
Oh, mustache.
Oh, oh.
Oh, a bird.
Electrical socket.
Okay, that's it.
That's all I have.
Yeah, that's all I have, too.
We got weapons.
How much?
Is it?
Oh, it's five.
I think we have all the weapons.
I think so, too, right?
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, I won't even let us do it anymore.
All right, whatever.
All right, it's time to save after that break.
It's time to save our friend.
We're very serious about it.
I mean, he waited all this time.
He could wait, like, two more seconds.
Oh, whoops.
That's true.
But what if those two seconds are, like, life or death?
When has it ever been that two seconds are life or death?
Like, like...
Whatever.
Nobody ever can give an example.
I'm sure there are certain circumstances in which it's life
or death for two seconds.
No.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
It's one of the...
Also, Barry, it's been almost two hours.
Oh, shoot.
We're playing the game.
Well, maybe I didn't mean an hour in, like, regular time.
Maybe I meant it in, like, bug time or something.
You don't know.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye.
Isn't that funny?
I think I have to launch you over.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Come here, come here, come here, run.
Okay, I'm here.
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
I think we need to time this.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, here.
Go, go.
Oh.
Did we just get worse at this game?
I think so.
Oh.
Wait for me.
It's over.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Oh, nice!
It says now I hold, I wait for you.
Do you think so?
Oh, thank you!
Oh, thank you.
Oh, we're fine.
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
You do that, and then...
I needed to turn off, though.
I needed to turn off those.
It's like a little bit...
There we go.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That...
Oh, my God.
Oh, and then I'll do this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Okay, nice.
Okay, let go.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Um, how do we get up there?
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
There is a gem there, but...
Oh, there is, yeah.
You can get it.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
I believe in you.
I can get it.
Thank you.
Thank you for believing.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I've gone without you.
Oh, we don't need gems.
Whatever, man.
What?
What even is that?
Look, exits open, guys.
Exits open.
Yeah, who care?
Oh, nice.
Oh, don't do that.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
Don't do it.
I did.
Don't follow my example.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
There you go.
And then I throw you over here.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, wait.
I don't think you needed to throw me.
That's fine, though.
Um, there's a...
There's a...
Okay, get in there, maybe.
And then go to the...
Yeah, yeah, nice.
Okay, where did that go?
Uh, I think I...
Open something.
Oh, okay, hi.
I'm here with you.
Okay.
Oh, let go of that?
Okay, yeah.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh, what in the world is going on here?
Okay, so you jump, and then when you get over there, I'll
let go.
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Okay, we gotta time this.
There you go.
How do we do this, though?
Oh, okay.
And then, and then I, okay, I see, I see, okay.
Do you want to time it?
Are you a good rhythm gamer?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, okay, sorry.
And then, and then.
Oh.
Okay, this is tough.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh.
What's controlling the other blocks?
I think it's just a timing thing.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
It was close.
Oh, it was close.
You got a P?
Okay.
Go P. And I'll be here.
Oh, oh, wait, sorry.
I did that too early.
Oh, okay.
Maybe you should do it.
I'm not a good at timing.
Okay, nice.
Nice!
Yeah, you're much better at the timing thing.
Oh, no, you have to do it!
Oh, God.
Wait, you're, like, inside of it.
Oh, I was close.
I probably will respawn here.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Oh, it's mine, it's mine, it's mine, it's mine, it's mine!
Until...
No!
I died.
Okay.
Oh, no, wait, the ball.
Wait, I think we lost the hat.
I think we lost the hat.
We definitely did.
It was my bad.
That's fine.
Everybody blame Barry Buck.
Oh, gosh, this part is like crazy timing.
Ah, you did it.
Anonymous hate mail.
The J Bezos at Amazon.com.
You got it.
J Bezos at Amazon.com.
Send all your hate mail there, baby.
It's probably like Bezos Daddy at Amazon.
Oh, you think so?
You think he has, like, it's not his, like, last, uh, first
name, last name?
No, I don't think so.
Oh.
Honestly, yeah, that, that might make sense.
How do I get out?
This is a pretty serious situation.
I'm stuck in here.
Oh, got it.
Oh, how do I get out of here?
How do I get out of here?
For real?
Oh, my God.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Are you stuck?
Are you good?
dog.
Wait.
I think you got it.
You got it.
Oh.
Well, anyway, it's fine.
Woo-o.
Uh-oh.
I woke the beast and I got the demi and we continue onwards
and I die.
And you'll awaken the beast and then you'll die.
Oh, what's wrong?
Oh, God.
Wait, this is...
Oh, oh, God.
Just go.
Go on without me.
okay i'm going i'm going i just wanted the gem uh well i
think we need to keep going up anyway oh yeah yeah yeah oh
my god no please oh my god i was stuck oh god oh god oh god
how did i get spawned here it's so hard to tell where you're
gonna get spawned yeah oh my god oh okay okay okay i made it
i made it all right oh nice nice you got it you got it i'm
waiting for i think he's after me i think you're fine maybe
or maybe i need to get through i need to get through Oh
shoot Well it's fine Okay welcome in Thank you Okay Nice Oh
not nice Not nice not nice Not nice Oh shoot
I did destroy your platform, my bad Okay there you go Okay
there you go Okay there you go I'm in a cycle of pain And uh
Uh uh No you got it!
You got it!
Yeah!
You're good!
Come on!
Okay.
Uh...
Hmm.
Oh, oh.
I can't tell what disappears, too.
I know.
Sometimes they disappear and sometimes they don't.
Oh!
Um, you need that rock.
I do need that rock.
How do I get that rock, though?
Get on my head.
Get up there.
You get up there.
There you go.
Hoi!
I think it's the other...
I think it's the... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, that was you, not me.
Come in here!
I can't!
Why?
Why does it spawn me there?
Get out of here.
Where does this go?
Oh, it goes into there.
Oh.
Oh, oh, God.
Where am I?
Oh, my gosh.
I can't.
How do I...
Oh, what?
Okay.
No, please!
Oh, my God!
Why were there two?
Oh, we're fine.
Oh!
Oh,
I got all...
We got all the thingies.
Oh, we're missing, uh...
Oh.
It's right there.
We can get this.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Yeah, you can get it.
Get it.
Yeah, you got it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
oh god wait no i i don't know oh shoot so close it's like i
don't know if that's even possible really it has to be oh
they're so not sometimes they get like out of sync sometimes
like now yeah yeah oh nice oh so close i looked like you had
it i know right okay hold on oh whoops oh oh oh oh
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh.
Go up.
There we go.
It was possible.
The mission was possible.
Yeah.
Oh, only five.
Only five, huh?
Yeah.
What the heck?
Guys, we've gotten every single time one.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
And by every single one, I mean like, not getting them, but
that's like the same thing, you know?
Oh, I got it.
Nice, nice.
And then you have to...
Hello?
Jump through?
Oh, there we go.
That's why.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, you got it.
You got it.
Wait, us.
Okay, and then... Okay, nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, this is fun.
Oh, this is...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh wait, what?
What did I do?
Anyways.
Okay.
What did I do, man?
Bye-bye.
Oh.
I died.
Oh, maybe you can.
Ow.
Oh, oh.
Maybe this way?
Um.
You have to help?
You have to cry?
Oh, yeah, you have to cry for him.
Come over here.
I'll go, too.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, now I'll go.
Well, I will.
Push me.
I don't think...
Oh, and then you call it over to you.
Oh, no.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
What?
Hello?
No!
Wait, where is he going?
He hates me.
Hi.
He actually hates you.
Okay, there you go.
There we go.
Yeah, you got it.
You got it.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, there you go.
Oh!
Oh, nice!
Yeah.
We definitely meant for that to happen.
Get out of here.
Eat me!
Um, I don't know where this is supposed to be.
Uh, I'm stuck.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Stop!
Get it!
Kill him!
Kill his ass!
Get him out of here!
Yeah!
I think we do have to move that out of the way.
Oh, oops.
Oh, there's fans there.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I go in.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, he's going?
Get out of here, man.
Oh, wait, what?
Maybe he poops us through, I think.
He poops us through.
I think we need to get him up here.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
There you go.
He's did it.
Oh, he did it.
Yeah, there you go.
Okay.
Yeah.
Get poop.
Oh, oh, oh.
It's okay.
Just go ahead.
Go ahead.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, there's a secret.
Where is it?
Ah.
Where could it be?
Just go through the teleporter?
He says it's this way.
No.
He says it's...
Somewhere.
I think we have to...
Wait, hold on.
Oh, wait.
No, not like that.
Not like that.
Oh!
What the hell?
Oh, you have to time it because...
Okay.
Okay, so not now.
Oh, I see when they grow back, okay.
Ah, like that.
Okay.
I got you.
Oh, oh, no.
Okay.
I'll get this first.
Wait, where is this?
Oh, no!
Can you break that one at top?
There we go.
Yeah, I got it.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh, where is the secret, though?
Maybe here.
Here.
Where?
Subware.
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, damn it.
Oh.
You got it?
Stop!
Why would you do it?
We weren't doing this!
Hattie, you're sabotaging me!
Oh my god.
You broke her concentration, Hattie.
Hattie!
Oh, fuck.
Oh wait, what the hell?
I mean.
How'd you do that?
I don't know.
Oh my god, please!
I'm so bad at jumping.
I hit my head every time.
It ain't- it ain't easy being a triangle head, you guys!
My hat!
Oh.
Please.
Okay, well, I'm gonna- No.
Oh, you got it.
Nice.
Don't lose it, though.
Don't lose it.
How did you- you toe-hold that?
Oh.
I was just such a toe-ho-er.
To-ho-er.
Wait.
Ah, fuck!
No!
No, no, no.
Hey, hey.
I knew that you were thinking- No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no!
No!
Oh my god!
You almost lost it!
You almost!
Ah!
Stop.
Truth, truth, truth, truth, truth, truth.
Yeah, truth, truth, truth, truth, truth.
It's brainwashed of that thing, man.
Oh, I know, right?
But it turns us into monsters, for real.
Ow!
Oh my god!
I hate this part.
I hate these walls.
It's because...
I don't know which way to put my joy pod, not joy pod, the
joystick.
Oh, I just put it against the wall.
Yeah, there you go, there you go, there you go.
But it doesn't go me, you make me go up.
It does this.
I think I need you to launch me for this part.
Okay, I need to, here, I'm just gonna die and go up there.
Hopefully.
I don't, oh, there you go.
Okay, okay.
No, I think you go against that block there, there.
No, yeah, but you need your double jump.
I know.
Oh, oh.
I see what you mean.
Okay.
Maybe...
Oh, oh, sorry.
The hat.
Go get the hat.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Okay.
See, that's what I'm...
I back out.
Okay.
Now what?
Now go and I'll grab you.
Oh, God.
Oh, thank you!
Yeah.
Mine!
Wait, but the yard!
We don't need the yarn!
No!
I wanted my gems!
Oh, you actually know we don't need the yarn anymore because
we can't buy any of our weapons.
Yeah, we don't.
Who needs the yarn?
It's for the cats anyway.
We're people.
Yeah, we're not cats.
I'm not, what do you think I am?
A grandma?
I'm not trying to sew here or crochet.
Yeah.
Yeah, we got the hat.
We don't crochet.
Oh my god, the air conditioner again.
Oh, loud.
It is.
Where?
I don't know if we can.
Yeah, I think we gotta go this way.
Okay, I'll go this way.
And then...
Wait, get off the...
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Okay.
Damn.
Alright.
And then...
Oh, wait.
Get that out of here?
Yeah.
Put that there.
Oh, wait.
And then...
Uh...
Hmm.
Okay.
Does that do anything?
No.
Uh, does that do anything?
I don't think it does.
It gets rid of a block, but I don't think it does much else.
Oh, we have to probably bring it over.
Wait, don't do...
Yeah, do this so that it goes over there.
Oh, wait, you did.
Oh, you did it.
Wait, what did I do?
What does that do?
Do I bring this up here?
Oh, you think so?
Wait, can I throw it?
Oh, no.
I don't think I can throw it.
uh can you try wait i'll grab it no i don't think so okay
okay then then we we probably just have to like get this guy
hold on not not that one we want it to be like the farthest
yeah okay like that wait no no no like this and then and
then oh wait hold on and then this i'm just like stuck in
here can't move like that what do you do do you get yeah
like we clear the block so he keeps going more more left
what does oh those guys oh I see what you mean okay okay and
then so oh yeah yeah let him go now get off there we go oh
no oh it's timed weird yeah okay you might have to go on
that There you go.
There you go.
Okay.
Nice.
That's good.
Yeah!
Oh, he's there.
He's there.
Okay.
What did that do?
What is he?
You got even anything?
I don't even know.
That might have not been anything at all, actually.
Wait, here.
Go.
Can you step on that so that...
Wait, here.
I'll step on this.
We're gonna make it...
Oh, wait.
No, you can't go down.
That's the thing is, this is going this way, so it's
difficult to do.
Did we come back here?
Like...
Wait, is there anything else?
This way?
Oh, wait, no, you can make it up there.
You can do it.
You can't put the rock there.
Wait, oh, you can?
Yeah, you can.
How'd you do it?
Oh, and you have to put the rock on the guy.
Oh, you can throw it?
Wait, how do you throw it?
Oh, how do you throw it?
You just, like, the attack button?
Attack button?
Oh, okay, okay, I see.
Okay, okay, wait.
Now don't hold him back over.
Wait, I was going to say...
Okay, you got to be careful not to do like a...
Because it'll go through.
Ouch.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
So one second.
Let me get it back up.
Okay.
Up there.
What?
How does this happen to me?
Okay, if you can time it so the rock lands on him.
Here, I'll do this.
There you go.
One second.
You got it?
One second?
I'm going to lift it.
Okay.
Lift it.
And then...
Okay, nice.
Oh, nice!
That's perfect!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, nice.
And now...
We do that.
And then now we do this.
Yes.
And then you do that.
That.
All right.
Okay, that?
Oh, the timing is so weird.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Yeah, nice.
There we go.
Let's show.
Oh, come on.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
No, no, you're good.
Oh, wait.
Yes, yes, please.
I can't get it back on it.
I can't get back on it.
Oh, you're just fine.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
It's okay.
We know what to do.
Okay, go.
Okay.
And then that's this.
And then that's...
That's okay.
All right.
Oh, how do we do this first time?
It's...
There's like a timing to bring back the...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Yay!
There we go!
Okay!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, my brain hurts.
I know.
My brain.
Okay, what is...
These are these batteries that we like can grab.
Or we have to like...
Oh, we can grab them?
Or no, we have to make them all the same.
You gotta equal them, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Got it.
There you go.
All right.
Can I go?
Okay.
Good.
Oop.
Nice.
Oh, I was too early.
Sorry.
I thought we timed that.
Okay.
You gotta be a little bit.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
Thank you.
No.
Okay.
Good to know.
Go, go, go.
I'm going.
Okay, alright.
Oh.
Let me wait for it to...
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Okay, it's gonna happen again.
Oh!
I always do that.
Wait, but it didn't like attack.
Oh, it does kill you.
Yeah, it does kill you for like a second.
Alright.
I'll stand on it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, you stand on it.
Okay, you will stand on it.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, that timing is so Oh, okay, okay.
Is good?
Yeah, yeah, we're good.
Okay, alright, let it go.
Okay, after this?
Okay, there we go.
Oh.
Okay, nice, uh oh, oh.
Okay, cool.
Perfect.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, oh, oh.
Aw, oh, oh.
Oh, nice!
Duh, not nice.
Oh, oh, whoa, what's going on here?
Hello.
What is going on over there?
A lot of stuff.
Oh my god.
Wait a second.
This is insanity.
Oh.
You did it.
Oh god.
Okay.
Thank you.
That's good.
Ah.
Well, thank y'all.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
It's so loud.
Okay.
Are you good maybe?
No!
Where's that going?
Oh, I need you to step on this, though.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Hold on.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait, what the heck?
There's a secret.
What is that?
Go in there, go in there.
Hey, that's it.
There's no more.
I think you probably might have gotten it.
Did I?
Okay, I'm stepping.
Yeah, I think you got it when you came in.
Okay.
Oh, dang it.
Okay, hold on.
It's okay, it's okay.
All right.
Okay.
Uh...
And you have to...
I think I have to step on this.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, nice, nice.
Uh...
What's this block?
Okay, can I drop?
Ah!
Okay, I'm gonna...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
We're fine, we're fine.
Oh, no!
Oh, no, no, no, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Okay, okay.
Okay, what do I step on to...
Okay, there you go.
Okay, that one.
Oh, no, no, no, no, I'm not through.
I'm not through.
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
And then...
Nice, okay.
This one.
Okay!
All right, all right, all right.
Oh, that's gonna start exploding.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
His brainwashed on that thing!
Oh,
oh, oh, oh!
Sorry!
No, no!
Oh, man.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
What do we do here?
Oh, we have to bring that, I think, yeah.
Uh, okay.
You can do that.
You can do it.
Hold on.
I'm doing it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
A lure, please.
Oh, oh, oh, no!
I died.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Very good, very good.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay, that must be it, right?
Oh, wait.
Oh, you need my head.
There you go.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
You did that.
Okay.
No, I didn't.
Grab me up.
No, no, no.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah, no, you would never, you know.
Oh, no, I would.
Ah!
If it falls in the lava, it falls in real life, very bad.
You've had the hat.
What if I want the hat more?
Do I throw you in there?
Oh, oh!
That's it.
Now nobody gets the hat.
Are you happy?
Why didn't we?
That was a B.
I was trying to throw you.
Well, here you go.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
This guy's gonna explode.
I think you have to...
There you go.
Oh, oh.
What is this?
Go away.
Okay.
Can you ride on this?
his head oh oh oh oh oh wait hello hold on watch this oh oh
don't watch it oh wait watch it watch it nice what about who
cares about the yarn who cares about the yarn Who cares
about the yarn ah?
We don't need it.
We didn't get that.
We didn't get the hat but we got the yarn.
We did get the yarn.
Oh.
Uh oh what is this?
There you go.
Oh oh oh oh.
That's pretty scary.
Oh.
You gotta slide.
Yeah.
You have to dash at the dash.
Okay.
Go.
I can't time it.
I'm scared.
Ah!
Do you?
Oh, the dash?
Okay, it's X.
No, you just have to hold down.
Oh, really?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Why can't I get this?
Why am I so bad at jumping, man?
Oh, wait.
Don't.
I don't know.
I've wasted my double jump every time.
Okay.
That's okay.
You got this.
Yeah, you just have to jump.
I get it.
Oh, oops.
Okay, we're fine.
Yay!
There you go.
Oh, watch out.
Watch out.
Oh, I see it now.
It's fine.
I got it over here.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's cool, guys.
I'm just gonna be here.
Okay, nice.
Um, oh.
Okay.
Nice, gem.
Nice.
What is this?
Oh.
What?
I don't know what I just said.
I know you can make it, though.
Whatever you decide.
However...
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh.
They tell you there's spikes down there.
That's so nice.
Four of them.
Wait, I can't.
Oh, wait, hold on.
What if I...
I just put my big ass body?
Was there anything down there?
Oh, I see what you mean.
I don't think so.
It doesn't...
Yeah, it doesn't seem like it.
I don't think you can.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
Yeah, go over there.
That might be...
Yeah, that might be the thing.
Oh!
The only thing is...
Oh, shoot.
How do you...
double jump yeah okay oh wait no stand on my head stand on
my head and then just jump once to get on the there you go
oh i think you need to do i think you need enough to go fast
enough to oh to um to just slide through okay you think
you're fast enough oh i don't think so oh my god okay oh i
messed up it's okay thank you oh dang it oh it's okay oh
whoops all right all right i'm gonna okay okay ah okay all
right all right all right one okay oh my god please okay
nice or maybe you you just kick are you good at kicking
kicking Like that?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, hello.
Oh, do the slide.
Do the slide.
Oh, but it's gonna...
Oh, wait, what?
The fan is gonna bring you down.
We're giving Tarzan.
I believe in you.
Okay, thank you.
Slide.
Oh.
Slide to the left.
Slide to the right.
How did I do that?
Criss-criss!
I don't think you can make it though because of the thing.
Oh, I made it.
I'm a huge liar.
Wait, what did that do?
I don't know, I'm afraid to get off the thing though.
Oh, it freed the guy!
It freed the guy!
Oh, my little friend!
There's a little pink thing!
I think you can probably leave then.
Right?
Oh, wait.
You're right.
Okay.
So I'm gonna go here and then you ride.
We ride at dawn.
Okay, and then you go to...
Oh, there you go.
Okay, and then you leave him there.
Oh, oh.
Okay, go down.
Oh, for the spikes, right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I think I have to leave him.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Come here.
God, you bitch.
He did nothing wrong.
What the hell?
He definitely did some stuff wrong.
Wrong.
Okay.
Why?
There we go.
Okay.
Are these the same?
I'm going down.
Oh, there's a gym over here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait.
No, I don't know if we can get that.
Yeah, we can, right?
Oh, you think so?
I hold it?
Yeah.
No, I don't.
I...
Oh, oh.
Because of the thingies.
Unless...
Hold on.
Go over...
Go...
Hold on.
But...
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, but the pants!
Oh, I don't think so.
I don't think so.
Oh, ah!
Yes!
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Okay.
No.
Careful.
Oh!
Oh, that didn't even touch me.
I'm saying.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, you are in my way!
Get on the, get on the button.
Yeah, and get button.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm, oh, nice.
You're here.
Have a nice one.
All right.
We're here.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh.
How do I do this?
How do you?
Oh, that's not it.
Oh, I use this block.
Oh, maybe not.
Oh, and then I probably get off of it once I go through.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry, my timing.
My timing, my timing.
Let me know.
No!
It's really...
It's tough, though, because you're going so fast.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, oops.
That was my bad.
I didn't mean to touch it.
Please, Debbie up.
Okay.
Go get it!
Oh, you're nice.
You're fine, you've hit it.
Yeah, we're good.
Yeah.
Oh, damn.
Oh, there's a yarn.
There's a yarn up there.
There's about that.
Oh, wee!
Oh, nice save.
Oh!
Okay, we're good, we're good.
She games like no one's over here.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Oh, this is the exit.
Oh, you have to, like, flappy bird this again.
Oh, oh, my bad.
Hold on, I want to flappy bird.
Flappy bird.
Oh, okay.
I guess I could do it like that.
What did you even do?
Like that.
What the hell?
Okay.
Flappy bird.
Flappy Bird, Flappy Bird!
Alright.
I don't uninstall Flappy Bird on your phone.
There's no way to get it back.
You can get it back.
Oh, watch out.
Oh, there's a checkpoint down there, so...
Oh, come on.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, oh gosh.
Okay.
Oh, oh, let me me turn it off and then you can go get it oh
never mind one of us will turn it off oh okay okay hold on
okay i will turn it off all right slide okay let me try to
hold on okay yeah go go okay nice okay i don't think you
have to even dash i think you can just run oh really no i
think you Wait, how do you do this?
Oh!
Oh, nice.
Oh, I turned off the wrong thing!
No!
Wait, why did you leave?
Well, I died.
Oh, you did?
Oh, I got it.
Wait, how did you do it?
You just ran?
Just ran.
Yeah, just run.
Oh, okay.
Okay, there you go.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
How did you die?
I don't want to talk about it.
That's fine.
Oh, what happened to me?
Oh.
You died, did.
I died, did.
I don't remember dying.
You don't remember dying to this?
No.
To the form you are right now, right?
Oh, where I am now?
I have no idea.
No, you do, right?
Oh, yeah, no.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
I became barbecue yakiniku, baby.
Oh, you made it!
Uh, how do I...
Oh, there we go.
Same thing happened to me!
Hey, we're here!
Alright.
Okay.
Wait, oh, do I need you?
I think you might...
Well, keep going.
Keep going.
Oh!
Alright, use my head.
Oh.
Okay.
Go, go, go up.
Oh, there you go.
Go, go, yeah, okay, nice.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, you're stuck in there.
All right, use my hand.
Okay.
Oh, wait, I do that.
Nice.
Just die, yeah, just die.
There you go.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
You jump?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Yep.
Oh, oh, oh, I'm sorry.
Okay, there you go, there you go.
Wait, oh, I don't think I still need...
Okay, there you go.
Oh, you got- Oh, no!
Just stay there.
Oh.
Uh, uh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay.
I'm telling, my timing is really bad.
Ah!
Just, uh, one more time.
One more time.
I'm gonna do that.
Okay, yeah.
Oh.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, oh.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, you're good.
You just gotta come over here.
Yeah.
Oh.
I think I ran out of steam.
Oh, oh.
Yeah, you have to keep pressing it, I think.
Oh, nice.
Oh, no.
Right at the very end.
Uh-oh.
Oh, this is the real Flappy Bird experience, I think.
This really is.
No!
Oh, the freaking lava!
Oh my god, please, please, please!
Oh, she is.
Damn it, damn it, damn it.
Oh, I'm just not a Flappy Birder.
Me neither.
I just ran straight.
Damn it, yeah.
Okay.
What?
Oh my god, please.
I guess you can't spam it.
I was right there!
I overestimated it.
Ah no!
What the?
Why am I back here?
Sorry, that was so funny.
I got to... Wait, me too!
Ah, see ya chub!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, no!
Wait, I don't understand how to control this thing at all, I
think.
I'm so confused.
Okay, one, and then...
Oh fuck.
Oh my god!
Okay.
No!
Why did it run out?
Why?
Oh my god!
I ran right into it!
Oh go to Flappy Bird.
We're stupid you guys.
We're stupid.
Oh my god.
Sometimes it runs out and sometimes it doesn't.
Sometimes it...
I know it's kind of random.
I'm like...
Oh, nope, nope.
Ah, trick!
No!
Why?
so that I can...
Oh, dang it.
Oh, damn it.
Oh my god, this is gonna be one hour of this dissection.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You got it, oh!
You got it!
You got it, you got it.
Oh, hello?
Just keep going.
I'll catch up.
Oh, I don't think I can.
Oh.
I need you to make it.
You need me!
I need you.
I need my needle.
Oh my god.
Shoot me!
Oh, because the thing is up there, I see.
Oh my god.
Oh, there you go, there you go.
Yippee!
Come here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, be careful.
Be really careful.
Yeah, I'll be careful.
Oh, hello.
A monkey over here.
Ah!
Oh, I need you.
I need you.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
Bye-bye.
There you go.
Now I need you.
Oh.
I need you to fly.
I can't fly this plane without you.
I will be your co-pilot.
Don't you worry.
There you go.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I think.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
It worked out.
Oh.
Oh, oh, I see.
Where does this do?
Oh, oh, wow.
That's a lot going on.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh, I think I have to...
I think we have to...
Get that up there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, to put on that block.
Oh, you almost got it.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Yeah, go.
Oh, shoot.
Oh!
Oh, it's closer!
So close?
Oh my god.
What?
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
Why is the place where it puts you is random?
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
No, you're dead.
Oh, maybe, maybe, maybe I just go there.
Here, I'll just do this.
Okay.
This might be easier.
Yeah.
Okay.
So then, but I still can't do it much.
No, the lava.
Yeah, there you go.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Oh, that's a fine place to put me.
All right.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, you got one.
You got one.
All right.
Hold on though.
Let me do it again.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Wait, I'm at the exit though.
That's true.
I don't know how to get you over.
Oh, I think you put it back up.
Wait, no.
I don't...
Oh, hello.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go...
Get it!
That was all of them!
I think?
Maybe?
Yeah, it was.
The shiny.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
But we didn't...
Who cares about it?
Who cares about the ball?
We got it.
Oh, you made that look easy.
Yeah, we did.
We made that look so...
All right, the final stretch.
Easy.
there guys we're almost there wait this doesn't oh it's over
here yeah eight seven eight seven eight seven
hello oh you got it no oh sorry yes you killed me i killed
you okay do you want to show shoot me?
Oh, okay.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh!
Oh, sorry, that was mistimed.
We're almost there.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Alright, I will launch you.
Okay, okay, you launched me.
Oh, sorry, that was my bad.
I wasn't close enough to the edge.
Okay.
Okay, okay, you just get ready to launch.
Okay, I'll be here.
Okay.
Oh, I'm launching you?
Oh, I'll launch you.
Okay, go!
Oh my god, I was so close!
I was holding R&D!
It was close, it was close.
It was so good, it's good.
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
I wasn't...
Go!
Nice!
Okay!
Okay, nice.
Um...
I think you want to...
Yeah, no, I don't think you need to do that.
I think you need to...
You want to get the blocks out of the way.
I think so, too.
All right, here we go.
Yeah, all right.
Nice.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, no.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, nice.
So close.
All right.
That was close.
Oh, shoot.
That would have been bad.
Don't die.
Okay, everyone die.
It's okay.
We did it, though.
Run!
Come here, Minto!
Oh, no!
Oh, wait, hold on.
Oh, okay, there you go.
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice!
Nice, okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, now what?
I'm gonna go.
I guess we just avoid...
What's this at the end?
Yeah, what's that at the end?
I don't know.
Oh, oh, it gives us a...
Oh, oh, oh, I'm gonna die.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, we both died.
Okay.
There we go.
There you go.
Oh, we just need it again.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
What the hell?
It disappeared for, like, so fast.
Yeah, it's...
It's pretty fast.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Oh, we're fine.
I haven't think it's good.
Oh, God.
What is this?
Just go.
Don't die.
Oh, my God.
So close.
Oh, no.
I
got it.
Nice.
Wait, this part, though.
Oh, God, oh, God.
I went so fast.
I didn't even...
Oh.
Sorry, I think I killed you there.
I think that was me.
I killed you.
Oh, no, I'm good.
Exit open.
Oh, man, I have to do that all over again.
No way.
I'm going to come to you.
If I go over here, I'm going to go.
You have to grab that.
Oh, and then you have to grab the block.
Go ahead.
I got it.
Nice, nice.
And then just stretch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's good.
Good job, good job.
Wait, I think if you...
Oh, there's a thing up there that you could hold.
Okay.
I guess maybe that was...
Now what?
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, why did I do that?
Don't laugh.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You're a little monkey.
I'm a little monkey.
Um...
What do you do here, though?
you get up there without dying i think maybe i have to go
over there and launch you
maybe it's like a one person okay i'm gonna make my way over
yeah yeah there you go like yeah there you go you're right
okay all right um i'm coming back okay oh oh yeah yeah yeah
oh i went the wrong way you almost got it oh good enough
okay Oh, that was close.
That was close.
Oh!
Oh, that was- Okay, okay.
Maybe I need to- Don't leave.
Don't- Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
There we go.
Nice!
Oh, you didn't need to get launched.
Oh, there you go.
Now, um...
Huh.
Question.
Oh.
Expand- Oh!
Yeah, use my body.
Use my body.
I'll use your body.
How was that?
Use my body.
Yeah, okay.
Yes, yes!
Yes!
Oh, well, that's not good.
Oh, oh, no.
That's not what.
Wait, how the hell?
Oh my gosh.
It's like the...
Maybe, maybe, maybe you have to...
It has to be there for a little bit.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, oh, oh.
The slimy.
It is so nasty.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm stuck.
Wait.
Oh, oh.
You might have to die.
You might have to...
Mito stuck?
Wait, what's going on?
Oh, I'm okay.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
What the heck?
What was even that?
What is this?
What's so interesting about?
Uh...
Huh.
Is there a secret here?
No.
Uh, move it away?
You do that?
Yeah.
And then punch him.
And then Mr. Kappa?
Oh, sorry.
Punch me.
Oh, dang, there's a thing.
Wait, where is he going?
Where is he going?
Wait, he's...
Do we have to, like, direct him?
Oh, no.
What is going on?
Where did he go?
I guess we have to, like, block him off?
And bloom in the battle block theater.
In the battle block theater?
Oh, wait.
I think we have to maybe...
the bladder bug we have to maybe like cut him off we have to
cut off his supplies yeah get him out of here you have to
stay in here man maybe oh what then he launches oh oh oh
whoa whoa whoa oh wait hold on oh no no that way no no not
that i think i think i hate you man i hate you uh i think we
need him to get it to stop wait no we need him down there
too though no wait once he's in there yeah yeah yeah yeah
now you go down go down you go down i go down yeah yeah hold
on once he goes back down okay you go down all right i go
down and see if he'll poop you out oh what he went he
cheated oh where are you going because i think anywhere with
the stop sign we need him there ish no right no he i think
he dies oh maybe i think maybe you block him off you block
use the three blocks to block off the top of the cloud the
cloud thing so he oh okay let's try that yeah he's sitting
on the thing yeah just punch him to make him go keep going
wait i'm trying he's punch him i can't punch him there we go
there you go okay uh well he's gonna he's gonna go okay no
but that's fine wait use the block the block his path block
his path There you go.
Okay.
Maybe he does die, though, when he sees the stop sign,
though.
What?
Where is he going?
What's he doing?
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, what?
Hello?
You were so close.
We were so close to greatness.
Go, go, go.
I was so close.
I'm fine.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I'll get it, I'll get it, I'll get it.
Before he dies.
No.
It's okay.
Yeah, okay.
Okay.
Now he should go over there again.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, he's gonna die.
It's okay.
He'll go this way and he'll go around.
Yeah, he'll go that way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're good.
Okay, you're good.
And then go around.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then he's gonna stop.
And then I just have to not die.
Yeah, you just have to not die.
Okay, there you go.
Nice!
Oh!
Whoa, hello!
Um, yeah.
I guess.
There's another old guy, though.
What the heck?
We probably missed a gem.
I think we missed a gemmy.
Maybe, maybe.
Oh, no.
I think we got all of them.
Never mind.
A bee!
Bee for berry bog.
Berry bog.
More like berry bad.
Oh, whoops.
What the?
More like maize minto more like Wade winto.
Wicked win.
Wicked winch.
Oh, I'm going to get crushed.
No, I'm not.
No, you're fine with me.
Oh, no, you're fine with John.
I tried to jump on top of it.
Wait.
Okay, I think I need to wait for it to, like...
Yeah.
I think I need to time it while I'm...
Or you could...
Can you jump on the...
Oh, hey, you can.
I can.
Okay.
Oh.
Hey.
Oh, hello.
What?
Ah!
I'm saying...
You saved you I live you oh, oh, are you trying to save me?
Yeah I'm pushing you down How are we supposed to do this
part though?
Oh, you just have to like when you when you do the dip.
Oh, it is like a dip.
Wow.
When you jump down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh Okay, okay.
You got it.
Okay.
Do I need the like the momentum here?
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, nice.
Nice.
You got it.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, wait a minute.
Get it?
Oh, okay, hold on.
Here, I'll send you.
There you go.
Yeah, nice, nice, nice.
Thank you.
Ah!
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, no!
I have to duck.
One of us will live and one of us will die.
it won't be me it won't be me it won't be me
oh oh god i don't have to do in this game oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what what is going on oh you
made it you made it okay i don't know what the game hates me
the game hates me it won't Wait, why the kids finally there?
Oh, oh, berry bug, please help me!
I'm trying!
Okay, there you go.
We're good.
All right.
All right, do your math.
Science.
Nice, nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, there we go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, you got it?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, come on, man, I'm getting spawn
killed.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, sorry, did I mess up your...
My flow, my flow.
My, your flow, sorry.
Oh, oh, oh, wait, why is that so slow?
That's so...
I know.
Oh, shoot.
Ah, I was so close.
It appears you have thrown off the maid's groove.
Oh, I'm so worried.
How did I time it before?
She's stuck in a loop, everybody.
She's stuck in a loop.
Not now.
That day is so fast.
really fast.
Oh, nice!
I inadvertently gave.
Oh, you got it.
You got it.
Okay.
Okay, I'll catch up.
Oh, shoot.
Me.
Yeah, that part's tough.
That part's tough.
Oh, my God.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
You got it.
Help me.
Again.
Help me!
Get it!
Yippee!
Let's go!
Help!
Help me!
Do you think if you were in like the Walking Dead, you'd
live?
No.
Me too.
I think I would be a day one victim, to be honest.
Use my body.
Use my body!
Oh.
Why'd you go the opposite way?
What was the point of that room?
Oh, there's a gem in here.
There's a gem.
Yeah?
Wait.
What?
Oh, I because you can't use a teleporter.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
We're good.
We don't need to go.
I don't think we need to go back in there anymore.
Okay, yeah, we don't.
Use my body!
Okay.
I'm using your body!
Yes!
Oh, wait.
How do you...
But how do you do...
How do I get over there then?
Yeah, how do you...
Oh, I see.
Oh, okay, I see, I see.
I can make it.
Oh, I made it.
Oh, look, yeah, you made it.
Look at the cat.
Oh, okay, be careful.
Oh, be careful.
Oh, no.
That stupid cat.
Cat.
Be careful.
I know, the stupid cat.
You're my body?
Be careful.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, so close.
Be careful.
Oh, I was careful.
I was careful.
You got it.
Be careful.
Okay.
Wait, this is hell.
What is going on?
Nice, nice, nice.
You did it.
I got it.
You did it, you did it.
Okay.
I think you just run, right?
I think you just run.
Yeah, I think you just run.
Nice!
Nice, nice!
You almost made it.
Oh, oops.
Ah, no.
How am I not, how am I not timing it now?
Yes.
Yeah, how did you make it?
Oh, nice.
Even have time to get the ball.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh!
I lose my double jump there, yeah.
Yeah, that last one is so bad.
Oh.
Wait, this timing is so...
Ah!
Oh my god.
You got it though.
Nice!
Oh.
Can I make... Oh, yeah, there we go.
Thank you?
There you go.
Hey!
Ah!
all right dude this is a little this is a little much isn't
it i hate these i hate i think i hate these a lot oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh wait this is so
you actually saved me but okay oh my wait did i die to the
thinger
Oh, come on!
What is going on?
Oh my god, please!
Please!
I didn't even land on that one.
Oh, come on.
Oh my god!
This guy's so dramatic.
Practice for Celeste.
So true.
Have you played Celeste?
I have played Celeste, like, not on stream, but, like...
I got it!
Oh, nice!
Nice!
You got it!
Woo!
Get it!
I'm stuck.
Oh, you're good.
You're good.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I made it.
I'm kicking you.
Okay.
I died.
But that's okay.
We're out of some sort of hellhole.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
We can.
Oh.
Yeah, I have not played Celeste.
Like, I played a few levels of Celeste, but...
Okay.
Are you planning on playing Celeste?
I thought so.
Probably.
It's hard, though.
Oh, my God.
It does seem like crazy.
Nice!
Oh, oh.
Wait, how do you do that?
You got it.
Oh, shit.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Stop.
Ouch.
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
Um, what are you supposed to do here?
Here, jump on my head.
Jump.
Okay, there you go.
Can you jump over?
Nice.
Oh, don't die.
Don't die.
Oh, it's okay.
We'll put this back here.
It's not so bad.
We good?
Oh, my God.
It's not so...
It's actually not good at all.
Wait, we need to kill this guy.
This guy needs to die.
We can't.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
Jump.
Jump over me.
Oh.
You can do it.
Stop!
Oh!
I'm making it!
Can't do it!
Oh no!
That's so messed up!
That was so close!
So messed up!
Okay, I got him for...
Oh, oops.
Oh, oh, oh.
He...
He revives so quickly.
Yeah, he does.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Oh, oh.
Ah, no!
He was blocking.
Okay.
Okay, go.
Go.
Oh, my bad.
Okay.
I was not locked in.
Oh.
It's okay.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Minto!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait!
That might have been awesome!
You scared me!
I gave you some, like, it was like a...
Thank you, yeah.
It was just like a little push that you needed.
Okay, okay.
I guess you could call it that.
See, everybody!
It's not murder if it works.
We did it!
oh it's time no way is this we're gonna save our friend
hattie haddington hattie haddington we're coming to rescue
oh all the dudes oh everyone who's had a hat all these dudes
dude number one wow oh don't that's dangerous wait there's
even a sock sock dude Dino, dude!
Oh, he's so cute.
What is this guy?
Cauliflower, dude.
Shortless, dude.
Like a mushroom, yeah.
Yeah, he's nasty.
Aw.
Wait, without dying.
Wait, what do you mean by the...
Nah, yeah, he's...
He's full of shit.
Yeah, he's full of shit.
Wait, come back here.
There we go.
Oh, I think you're supposed to slide technically?
Or maybe?
Actually, I don't know.
Oh.
What just happened?
I attacked him once.
Ah!
Get him!
Yeah, nice, nice!
Oh, I have to help save you.
There you go.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, oh, little guys.
Little guys.
Go!
Onward!
Oh, dude!
Okay.
Nice.
Come here, come here, you guys.
Come here, you guys.
Come here, you guys!
Wait.
What is going on?
Oh, you go through there.
Okay.
Wait, no, huh?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oops.
Just keep going.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, oops.
Oh, why do they move?
I don't know.
They're so annoying.
You're supposed to be my little guy.
And he's...
Okay, come over here and go to my head.
Okay, can you jump over?
Oh, that was so close.
Oh, my God.
Ouch.
How are you supposed to do this?
I didn't even move.
I didn't even move, I swear.
Sorry.
Ouch.
Wait, can we just cheese it?
Can you just jump on my head?
Like here?
Like, yeah.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
Yes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, but now I'm stuck.
Oh, oh.
Oh, no.
Wait, no.
We have the checkpoint.
We should be spawned there.
Oh.
There you go.
Keep going.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Close.
Wait, this is good.
This is good.
It could be better.
It could be...
Okay, okay.
It's okay.
Oh!
So close.
I think you just single jump, maybe.
At the very end.
Okay.
Oh, nice!
Oh, so close.
Wait.
Thank you.
Oh, oh, oh.
You gotta be careful of the...
Yeah, you gotta slide after.
Oh, shoot.
We don't even need that.
Oh, that was you, not me.
Ah, okay.
Yeah, we don't even need that guy.
Wait, wait.
Okay.
Oh, oops.
Where are we?
You're at the top now.
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Oh, I got a jetpack.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, my.
Come on, jetpack.
Oh, it runs out so fast.
Oh, there's a Jimmy though!
Oh, oh.
I'll get it.
get it oh no i will okay but i'll work towards getting it
you work towards going over okay okay oh okay oh i got it
nice nice nice okay oh god oh god math oh god okay there we
go there we go oh i got it the other one i got the other one
oh okay nice oh wait jump jump jump jump jump got it there
you go there you go no go oh i think i need you to launch me
oh here or Oh no, we're not gonna make it!
Ah!
That's tough!
Oh my gosh, okay.
Oh.
That's tough.
Happy birthday to your kitty pear!
Happy birthday to your kitty!
Happy birthday!
It's this guy.
This guy's a huge time sink.
There you go, there you go, there you go, there you go.
Nice, nice.
And we'll just cheese this part again as we did before.
Oh, okay.
Okay, cheese.
Oh, wait, but we need a coin.
Come on, come on, come on.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Okay.
Nice.
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump,
jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump,
jump, jump, jump, jump!
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, wait, you gained!
You gained!
Come to me, come to me!
I'm coming, I'm coming?
Okay, wait, you might have to move a little bit out of...
Oh, oh, you're right.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, there you go, there you go.
Oh, that's so bad.
Oh, uh...
Oh, man.
Oh, oh, you have to, like, actually...
Oh, well, not that help.
Wait.
Oh, oops.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, God.
Okay, you know what?
just just move on we don't need the ball of yarn oh i
thought you were oh i didn't even realize i thought you
could you had to go that way oh okay just kidding no no you
don't have to oh okay i'll get the go i'll get the gemmy
again or oh that's what i'll okay okay oh come on i didn't
even press that button okay okay nice well never mind i'm
not getting the gemmy but that's okay all right We can get
this one?
We can get this one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Now...
Yeah, nice.
Oh, just go!
Just go!
Okay, I'm going, I'm going!
Wait, this is tough!
Uh, how did we get up there?
There you go.
Let's go.
Okay, but I think I need you.
Uh, hold on.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, man.
Oh, I don't think so.
I don't know how to get up there by myself.
No, wait, this is tough because I think I definitely need
you.
How do I get up there though?
Here, I'll try.
I'll try.
Wait.
Oh.
And how do you do this?
How do I get over there?
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Ah!
Ah?
Did we do this out of secret or something?
No, I don't think so.
There's no way.
Ah?
Happy New Year's Eve!
How do we do this?
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know either.
What the heck?
You can pull up?
We are pulling up.
Yeah, it's just I'm not...
I can't even make it.
I can't read.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Wait, what?
We were doing that the entire time!
We were!
Well, it's okay.
We got this.
We got...
That's very strange.
Okay.
Now we lock in.
Okay, go.
Just ignore him.
Go, go, go.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that's right.
Go, go, go.
I'm trying.
Call him, call him.
Help, help, help.
Wait, why did you do that?
Why did you...
Oh.
Oh, okay.
We got it, right?
Yeah.
Oh, you got it?
You got it?
No, I didn't get the gem.
I didn't get the gem.
Oh, you didn't get the gem.
No, I died.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Now we're good.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Nice, nice, nice.
I did.
Oh, bad.
You were two gamer that first time.
Oh!
Oh, nice!
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
I'll make it.
I live.
I didn't live.
You got the gemmy!
Okay, okay.
Oh, shit.
I made it?
Oh, I died?
No, you gotta duck on that.
Oh, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I think maybe...
What?
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how is it?
I'm able to get these...
I don't...
Okay, hold on.
Wait, uh...
How did I get it before?
I just focused on the bottom one.
Oh, I was focusing on the top one.
There you go.
But we need the top one too.
Wait, hold on.
Wait.
Oh, wait, you're right.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God.
I like how you still have the jetpack.
Oh, do I?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
How have we gotten this before so many...
So easily.
Oh, there's also this other gemmy here.
Get that?
There you go.
Okay, nice.
Oh, my God.
I'm too stressed to, like, even think about it.
I always just...
Stay left!
Leave it alone?
Nice!
Okay, autour!
Come on!
Get- okay, it's okay!
It's okay, it's good!
Yeah.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, hold on.
Okay, okay, here!
You go first and I'll climb on your head.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Oh, why don't you use your jetpack?
I don't have a...
On my screen, it's a visual glitch I think.
Oh, okay, okay.
There we go.
Alright, alright.
Let me go.
Okay, okay.
Oh, shoot.
I think you would jump from that to top.
Here?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
How did you do that?
I don't know.
How do we do this?
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
That's okay.
Go.
Nice.
Okay.
Get the flag.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you do with that?
I don't know.
Maybe I...
It's okay.
I'm coming.
I think I use it to...
Oh.
Maybe, oh, no, it's okay.
Oh, you got it.
Okay, I got over.
I got over.
Okay, we're good.
Okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go,
go, go Okay, let's go.
Oh, go, go, go, go.
Oh, this way, this way, this way.
Oh, oh.
Sorry.
There we go.
I got it.
Okay.
Just keep going.
I'm going.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
I don't see a checkpoint anywhere.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, you got one.
Nice.
Yeah, it's right here.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I got it.
It's actually not that bad.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Go, go.
Oh, sorry.
That's okay.
Here, I can grab you.
Thank you.
Okay.
And then this way.
Do I throw you?
Hold on.
Can you kick, maybe?
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
But it's just a yarn.
It's just a yarn.
It's okay.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Throw you over there?
Oh, oh, oh, I think you need to go.
Oh, wait.
Oh, you think so?
Yeah.
There you go.
And then I do.
Oh, okay, you got it.
Oh, what the heck?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, what?
Wait, what's happening now?
Oh, my God.
What's happening now?
I don't know.
You, like, freed something.
We freed something.
Yeah, we did.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Close, close.
Okay.
Okay, wait, hold on.
All right.
I don't know how I'm supposed to do anything here.
Yeah, right.
You go up there.
Go, go, go, go.
Wait.
Why is it opening now?
Why is it it?
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
How are you supposed to do this part?
That's tough.
Oh, go, go, go.
Oh, what is happening?
I don't know about this one.
Fairy bug.
Oh.
Yeah!
I need to be so much higher.
Can we get much higher?
Oh, you have to make it...
Okay, okay, I think you got it though.
I don't know.
Oh my god, no!
Sorry, sorry, that was...
It's such bad timing.
Okay.
Oh my god, no!
It's okay, it's okay.
We have infinite strides.
Please!
Here, I think you need to go again.
Or, oh my god.
Oh, nice!
Nice, nice!
That part is so tricky!
So high!
Why does this boom do this to us?
Oh, okay.
We call the thing, yeah, call the thing.
Call, call, call, call, call, call, call, call, call, call,
call, call.
Okay.
Oh!
Go, go, go!
Go!
Up, up, up, up, up.
Um...
And then we go this way.
Oh, nice!
Uh...
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, wait, uh...
There we go!
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go!
Ah!
Damn it, okay.
Oh, God.
Oh God, oh God, oh God.
It's been unleashed, whatever happened here.
Alright.
Go, go, go!
Oh my god, the timing here is so tricky.
Ah, damn it.
Okay, you go, you go.
I think you might be closer.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god, please.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
Every time that one stinking thing for me.
okay okay i think you're getting it i guess you just have to
like spam it i don't know man i don't know guys this one's
hard you're getting it you're getting farther than i i am no
i'm getting the same place as you no i think i die at the
first no no you got you die at this last one you do
I'm dying, I'm dying, I'm dying.
I'm dying.
Okay, just move on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know how to...
Okay, I need you though.
Yeah.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, no, not that way.
Uh, yes, but no.
I think.
Oh, shoot.
Um, let me see.
Oh, do you need me to?
Wait, but I can't get it.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, that's why.
That's why.
Okay.
You go.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, oh, my bad.
My bad.
Okay, I'll hold it.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, what does this do?
Okay, so I have to hold here.
Uh, wait.
Oh, oh.
Okay, there you go.
Wait, where does it go to, though?
Uh, I go to lava.
There's nothing.
Oh, I think I...
Okay, I can time it.
I can time it.
Here you go.
Oh, I'm bad.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where do I go though?
I don't know where to go.
Up.
Oh, my God.
My tippy toe is precedent.
Okay.
All right.
Here you go.
Oh, my God.
I do that.
And then...
There you go.
There you go!
Nice, nice, nice!
Okay, I have to do the same thing.
So you have to get off of it every now and then.
Okay.
There you go.
All right, there you go.
Nice!
Huh?
Shut up, Hattie!
How do you...
Oh!
Oh, I don't know.
Okay.
Oh, we're almost there, though!
Oh, gosh!
Oh, God!
Just go!
Okay, goby Ah Okay, oh, oh, oh!
Wait, wait.
There we go, there you go!
Okay, there you go, can you!
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump!
Jump, jump, jump!
Ahhhhhhhh, no!
Oh wait, I have to go the other way!
Wait, hold on.
We can do it!
Do it!
Come on!
Oh, wait that's not it!
No way!
What?
What are you right!
Oh, okay.
We are right there!
Okay.
Go.
Oh, go.
Oh, oh, oh.
Nope.
Yes.
Nice.
Oh, that was close.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ah, not this jetpack session.
I know, we have to do this again.
Okay, you do it, you do it.
This is such a time sink.
It's such a time sink.
Oh, shit.
Oh, where am I?
Why am I all the way over there?
No, why?
Why does it hate me?
Why?
Wait, why?
Give it to me!
Wait, why is it doing that?
Oh my god.
My head.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, here you go.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Nice!
Oh my god, I didn't even realize I got it.
Oh, it's okay, it's okay.
Oh, Berrybug, this part's hard!
I believe in you!
It's okay!
It's okay.
I know it's hard.
Take your time.
It's fine.
It's totally fine.
This is like the longest section.
So you can spend however long you...
Oh shoot!
Please!
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
I'm killing myself!
Kill yourself!
Okay, I'm killing...
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, no, no, I'm not like that.
I'm intended.
No distractions!
Okay.
distractions okay all right i need you to okay yeah yeah
okay okay okay i'm doing it oh okay oh i think i'm gonna die
oh oh oh no i'm gonna go okay we're good okay nice nice nice
nice nice go down all right good job good job okay good job
good job okay now this is this again this again okay oh oh
my god oh okay all right okay oh shoot oh shoot that oh oh
oh nice nice you're I lived, I lived!
Okay, go, go, go!
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
That was my- That's good, good, good.
I'm so sorry!
Oh, oh, it's okay!
Go, go, go.
Wee!
Oh, oh, where?
Oh, oops.
No way, I put you all the way back down there.
Oh, oh my god, are you kidding me?
Oh, good, good, good, good.
Okay, now I do this, I think?
I guess?
Okay.
Oh, oops.
Oh, wait, no.
Get me- get me on there first.
Get up there.
Okay.
And then- and then do that.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
So close, so close.
Okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, okay, do that.
Oh.
Oh shit.
It's okay.
We have 30 seconds.
Okay.
What?
Oh, wait.
Oh, my bad.
My bad.
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh.
Do
it.
Oh, he's dead.
He's definitely dead.
No, he's not.
Something's very wrong here.
If you can't carry yourself, then we'll carry it for you.
Yeah.
Get out of here.
We gotta run.
Oh, we gotta go.
I took a medal.
I have a trophy, too.
I have a trophy.
Woo!
Oh, my.
Wait, they have, like, guns.
And so we finally made it back to the boat.
We did it!
Is that it?
Is that the end of the game?
I think that's it.
Oh, my God.
was unpleasant to the point of sucking the whole but now
it's time to relax oh that was tough holy prick whatever
that means and treat ourselves to a nice big mug of hot
cocoa oh that sounds good i'm gonna get some hot cocoa that
does stuff oh yeah no i think he's dead he didn't even
respond to hugs freaking hugs he loves hugs i i think he's
dead he wasn't even blinking i think he's dead
What is this?
Wait, we did all of that, but it was not even...
We tried to... Wait.
Wait, he's just dead.
After all that, he's dead.
After all of that, he was dead.
Yeah.
No!
No, we were too late.
Wait, this is so relatable to our actual game.
play this is so sad mega 64
jesson beaver jesson kimberlake what just in time davy
crockett i love you hattie hattie oh blah blah but you know
what they say life gives you potatoes you make potato salad
and i got just the recipe hit it buckle your pants pull up
you know what i'm talking about yeah yeah those big pants
boys and girls of all ages buckle your pants or they might
fall down hey you
Buckle your pants!
Why are they telling us to buckle our pants?
Why are they telling us to do that?
I have no clue.
I think I'm confused, but...
It's just the ending credits, I guess.
Buckle your pants, buckle your pants.
Because my pants will fall to the ground.
Otherwise, you'll be the fool who ripped his pants.
Or dropped his pants.
Yeah, he dropped his pants.
Has your pants ever ripped on you?
Oh, oh, he's actually...
I saw this compilation recently of people, like, ripping
their pants.
And I was like, oh, my God.
I forgot that was a thing that happened.
Wait!
He has the hat again!
Oh, the hat is calling!
Wait, what's going on?
Do you press?
Oh, oh, are we...
Wait, what just happened?
I pressed the button and it ended.
Wait, did we skip the...
Did we...
Did I skip the cutscene accident?
One more time?
I mean, it was probably gonna end there.
Wait, is there not like a...
There's got to be like a view video, view movie, right?
I think, yeah, surely.
Level, it's not a level editor.
Achievements?
Oh, we're so fucked.
Wait, hold on.
Battle block theater ending.
I think we're at the very end.
No, we earned this.
We earned this, guys.
We could do this.
Will you send me a link?
Oh, shit.
Wait, we were not at the very...
There was like a minute left.
Yeah, I'll send you the video.
Screen capture that.
Okay, hold on.
It means screen capture.
My bad.
I thought it was over.
And I also didn't expect clicking it to...
Wait, I gotta exit the game then.
I think so that the...
doesn't overlap wait one second oh yeah yeah all right well
we're done with that game anyway yeah we're done with it we
did it we did it okay we did it we did it i can't believe
i'm i'm playing it i'm playing it wait wait a second hold on
i haven't played i haven't got there yet okay let me know
when you're playing it okay hold on hold on i gotta make it
small okay wait why is it so cropped strangely one second
guys one second team it's it's funky it's funky funky funky
night Okay, okay, yeah, yeah.
What's happening?
Buckle your pants!
B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B.
Okay, take your time.
I'm almost there.
All right, I'm closing the game.
I'm closing the game.
executive okay and then okay
all right okay i'm ready to play all right okay ready yeah
go okay this is where we were at everybody yeah this is
where we were at don't mind the one minute left of because
there's nothing that we skipped
this this is a lot man this feels like pretty important wait
i think we lost oh shoot did we did we lose in the end oh it
just says the end now i get it yeah i think that i guess
that was it it all makes sense now that was it see yeah we
only had like five seconds left that was it you guys wait
what what well
whatever man you know what that's fine It's fine.
It's fine.
Yeah, we did it.
We beat the game.
We beat the game!
We beat it!
My ass will not get beaten outside the Jazz Minto Club.
And it only took us three hours.
Yeah, three hours is practically one hour.
This whole time you were like, we have one hour left.
We only have one hour left.
Yippee!
Oh, guys, we did it.
We did it.
We freaking did it.
We did.
Actually, we did yapp for a bit earlier, though.
We yapp for, I think you could say we yapp for like two
hours.
It just flew by that quickly, everybody.
It was like so fast.
I'll see you mother freakers again.
We'll see each other again this weekend.
We will.
Oh, yeah.
collab we got a collab next densetsu collab yeah i forgot to
put what game it was on my schedule it was just like
beasties densets i think i think we took a while to like
confirm what game it was anyway though to be honest that's
true that's true no wait wait no it's fine actually yeah it
was actually three hours of yapp and 10 minutes of gameplay
we actually finished 10 minutes.
Yeah, it's true.
It's true.
Oh my gosh, I get to put it in my completed games list.
Yay!
And I only have one more.
December 30th, 2025 Battle Block Theater.
Yay!
You did it!
We did it.
You carry so hard.
No, man.
That jetpack session was all you.
Oh, no.
That was...
I don't know how I did it, though.
I could not have done that Well we did it It doesn't matter
We did it We did it That's why we're a team Yeah that's why
we're the bento team The bento The bento Delicious Yippee
Thank you for the super time Thank you Thank you guys For
all coming by Be sure to check out Minto as she finishes her
50th game tomorrow whoa wait wow I have you in my game don't
I oh right oh my god wait I totally right oh my god can you
believe that it's been like a like a year it's been like
yeah it's been a year I remember cuz you asked me about
being in your game and I was like I remember when you asked
me I was like oh wow I'm I'm so touched that uh like because
i don't think at that point we only met like once i think so
i was like i i want to i want to be friends but i also don't
want to overstep you know i knew that we would be bestest
friends so that's why i put you in my game what the hell i
had a feeling what the hell
though that we're such good friends now yeah i love minto i
love berry bug what though what though
i'm gonna cry don't cry you'll make me cry hey you cry i cry
i'm super excited for oh my god this year is coming to a
close what What a...
What a year.
For us, yeah.
But...
But we're still doing...
We're still kicking.
We're still here.
You know, as William Afton always says, I always come back.
I always come back.
I will put you back together.
I need a Freddy friend bear to help me put me back together.
Yeah, we need the yellow Golden Freddy...
plushy yeah yeah yeah my goodness gracious goodness gracious
indeed goodness gracious yeah are you are you wrapping up or
are you gonna continue to stream what's the plan uh my
migraine hasn't gone away yeah i think you should i think
you should definitely rest up I think I will also rest up.
Yeah, you should rest up too.
Let me see.
Who is online?
Who's online?
Sorry, guys.
Since I did a couple of streams that were longer recently,
I'm going to.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Definitely.
Sorry.
Of all days that I need my brain the most, I have a migraine
today.
No.
Oh, Ashton's online.
Ashton's online.
Wait.
I'm pretty sure Ashton should have YouTube raids on.
on yeah yeah what is youtube oh wait berry bug is on
don't rate her i hate her yeah she pisses me off wait i
think i need to oh i didn't realize ashton also wait why
don't i subscribe to ashton sometimes i get people in my
ashton martin no sometimes it's tough to tell because i mean
ashton and i and mimi are all like on twitch We still do
do...
Yeah, because I follow you all on Twitch, so I forget...
Wait, actually.
And you hate Twitch.
I hate Twitch.
Yeah, I hate Twitch.
Oh, yeah, there we go.
Okay, I have her now.
Oh, she is live.
Okay, she's doing her Donutan even, so...
Yeah!
We can go encourage her Donutan.
Yeah.
How long has she been going for?
I have no clue.
Oh, how about this?
I've put on a thing, so it looks like we're at a concert.
together.
What did you put on?
I put on an OBS thing.
An OBS thing.
An OBS filter.
Wow.
Fancy.
Yeah, I can show you later.
It's really nice.
Wait, did I?
Okay, change is saved.
I think I did it.
All right.
Yeah, show me later.
Yeah, let's read it to Ashton.
Okay, let's read it to Ashton, both of us.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Actually, I might be a little lagged because I want to
think... Oh, of course.
yeah oh i want to talk a little bit too so oh yeah yeah okay
then um whoa we'll raid we'll raid we read we read yeah
thanks for coming everybody thank you for having me me too
and i booze i'm gonna talk to the i'm gonna talk to the my
chat my bug bros wisps near my whisk i'm gonna talk to my
wisps
uh we're talking now darga thank you so much for the peek of
all games have a with a migraine i know and it's so much
happening i'm so sorry guys i didn't want to like be like
guys i don't feel well today so that's what that's my crutch
but oh my goodness i think i think i actually need to go um
to like the boost fiddle or something because uh recently
like um i had an ocular migraine for the first time and it
was in my left eye and then my i've been and migraines all
behind my left eye i don't know i don't know like uh if it's
i went to the i got the eyes checked somewhat recently so i
think that maybe it's not my eye hope it's not my brain
that's just a bunch of ectoplasm goo in there i shouldn't be
anything is it the crow country curse maybe it did start
yesterday but i have like uh like uh recently just behind my
left eyes and i took some i took medicines and it didn't
help at all so it sucks yeah i should go get it checked out
blood pressure but i i have no blood Ectoplasm pressure,
maybe.
So, yeah.
Stress over-exerting my eye muscles, maybe.
Who knows?
It could be.
There's so many things it could be.
There's so many things it could be, so I apologize.
I
put in my, I put my, um, my controller.
What if I did this?
Wait, will she see this?
She's looking at me.
She's like, whoa, sick tricks.
Whoa, me, oh, wow, what is she doing?
I can do it to her, too.
Wow, Barry.
You got the sick moves.
Barry Bug, everybody.
She's just a spinning bug.
She's the spinning bug.
What if I press this one?
Oh.
What about this one?
Help!
Whoa, weird.
Please get checked out, better safe than not.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you, Dargo!
Thank you so much!
Evan!
I have some good news to share.
I submitted my last Calculus 3 assignments today.
Thanks for being the ghost in my head, Jeremy, and I'll be
better safe than mine.
Thank you!
Wait, let me get big again.
I look like a sticker.
I looked like a little sticker or something.
We'll keep buried.
This is like an accurately sized ladybug, no?
Smaller, smaller.
Congratulations, Evan!
I love Minto!
I love Mr. Yum Yum!
Thank you!
Bro, welcome to membership!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I love Minto!
Really?
Sticker Minto.
Attach it to my earbud case or something.
That'd be so good.
Really, really.
Why do I sound like that?
What's this button do?
I had so much fun today, guys.
But I will.
What is she doing?
Why is she like that?
Why is she confused now?
Oh, that I'm going to eat her.
10 out of 10!
You want to watch me make this bug?
disappear
there's a bug in my hair
would you would you get this bug out of my head I mean wait
out of my hair wait one second could you do me a solid no
what do you mean no wait I know who would do the job
do You came!
You came!
Thank you so much!
Can you get her?
Goodbye, Barry!
Thank you!
Magic trick!
Wait, how do I get her back?
Wait, I miss her.
That's me!
That's you!
I accidentally clicked the screen and paused.
I gotta get her back.
Wait.
Barry.
I didn't mean it.
Barry!
Barry back.
She's probably fine.
Thank you guys so much.
We have one more game tomorrow to finish.
To beat 50 games.
Oh!
Also, I feel like I'm not gonna beat.
Or rather, I'm gonna probably finish the game.
I might be...
Oh, I might be silly.
Um, boss, I think there was a bug on that hair I ate.
You ate it?
Aren't those poisonous?
Are you gonna be okay?
Do you need the antidote or CPR?
Chest!
Compressions!
Wait!
I don't...
I'm all goo!
I can't breathe!
Call Nimi Call a nurse But what was I saying?
Oh, if it takes me not so long to beat Freak or Treat I also
Then we'll play Mind Sweeper And we will try to beat Mind
Sweeper Before the new year Hopital That's where I'm off to
Minto, everybody!